Hello, everybody.
Hello, hello.
We're back with more Batman.
Batman.
Do you guys know?
Fun fact.
You know, like, the old Batman show with Adam West.
Yeah, not the family guy, Adam West.
Like, the actual... I mean, he is the actor who was in Family Guy, who also played himself.
But before he was on Family Guy, He was also in Batman.
And back then, apparently, he would go to lots of orgies in his Batman costume.
And there's apparently in one of the orgies that Adam West went to in his Batman costume, him and the guy who played the Riddler, they both got kicked out of this orgie.
because they were two in character.
So the guy who's also playing the Riddler in that show, they both got kicked up because, you know, they were role-playing as the Riddler and the Batman.
So, is that such a fun fact?
I riddle me this, Batman.
They got kicked up because they were two.
They were two kicked.
And it's like, mmm, if you have to, if you want your release you gotta solve this riddle riddle me this based app now apparently adam west was a freaking freak like you yeah oh i mean like i i i mean like i guess because like hollywood but uh don't phrase it like this um took you less than five minutes into the stream thank you for the super chat osni thank you Thank you.
But wasn't it a fun fact, guys?
Lita, thank you for the Aka Supa.
Thank you.
Joki, take care of yourself.
You want to give me hope?
Help me through tough times.
We Juggins will never give up on you.
We are real and we are here for you.
Thank you for the Aka Supa.
Aka, Aka.
Oh, my God.
DJ, thank you so much for the Aka, Aka Supa.
Really appreciate it, Lita.
Thank you always for all your support.
for it man um but yeah no i thought apparently there's even more stories you know i did i didn't realize the character like i thought he was playing a character in um in family guy but that's actually him like because like back then when he was a lot younger during the batman days he was apparently a freaking freak so like he wasn't like the character of family gap was sort of based wild stories he used to do back in the Batman day like that's just how that's just how he was like that's it's just him like the fact that like he brought the costume with him during during the the fun sexy time this is wild in the back that like you know he took his orange cheese too I was like,
what?
Well, yeah, nobody messes with Adam West.
It wasn't Adam West as himself.
It was Adam West as Adam West.
But yeah, what a fun fact.
Also, I liked how I played Marvel Rivals at night and at DC in the, well, in the morning and technically in the evening.
But that's true unity.
Marvel Rivals at D-Gen Hours in DC in the evening.
Yeah, Adam Freaky West.
Also, another, an update.
There's a lot of updates.
There's a lot of hashtag ad updates and a lot of like regular updates.
But hashtag ad update.
We have a new voice pack up on the store right now.
I don't know if I, let me get the graphics real quick.
Let me save the graphics.
But yes, new Halloween voice packs are out, is out in the store.
right now so uh we recently hired a new script writer to handle writing scripts and stuff for uh for me so um pretty exciting and also we have staff that's working on um the only issue with the issue of like voice packs and stuff is finding artists and contacting artists and everything and i don't have time for that so uh we recently delegated um uh like look locating and communicating with artists and stuff to a staff member and also we hired a script writer to also handle that as well so I don't have to worry about that anymore all I have to do is just record which is great like less work for me um so and with that we are also launching like additional merch along with the voice packs so the illustration um there's an option to also get um to also get like a button and also a snapshot as well with the of the illustration so obviously like you can just get the voice pack in the wallpaper or you can there's an option to just get the snapshot or even the snapshot and button so yeah let
me post the dokey merch site right now um i did hear there was issues with the shipping prices um the staff is working on it at the moment i saw it in there are just like i said i don't handle majority i don't handle like the business side of the shop but i do have access to the group chat not group chat to the server of how the shop is being handled and everything so they are like um they are working on it i'm not sure exactly um how it's gonna go but i did see discussions about it um it's just because they don't have the items on hand at the moment um because it is pre-order for the snapshot and buttons so the snapshot buttons are pre-orders at the most so they don't have So they don't really know,
like, I guess they're just like, oh, since we don't have the items on hand is like what we believe the price should be.
But they are discussing about it because they're like, oh, yeah, it does seem a little bit more expensive than it should be.
But yeah, they're figuring it stuff out.
They're figuring it out right now.
I'm not sure exactly what is going on fully, but they are figuring it out just because I'm not in charge of the shop anymore.
There's a lot of numbers on there.
So, I have other stuff to deal with.
Anyway, other than that, another update I'd like to give you guys is that I will be participating next week in the Street Fighter New Challengers Tournament.
team nephew so i was contacted by um capcon um because i know you guys were like i thought you won't do another like say jam slap this isn't say jam slam or like i thought you weren't going to do another tree fighter thing well um i said yes to this because i was contacted by um capcon um I was contacted by CapCon,
I think like a month ago, a month ago, a month or a month and a half ago.
I don't really remember whether or not I would like to participate in this.
And the thing is, they told me that it doesn't mean I would get picked because it is a drafting phase because people were like, oh, oh, wait, you didn't, you're not with like Brawl Pro because Brawl Pro is in this tournament as well.
and also in an hour my food's going to be here so we're going to eat while we're streaming too because I'm so fucking hungry anyway so they told me that it was a drafting phase so I don't even know how the drafting was done because it was done behind closed doors and they were just going to contact the people that got drafted in or got picked by by the captains which were the you know the FGC players.
So what I was told was that me signing up doesn't necessarily mean that I would get in.
So I was sort of surprised that I got in because I assumed they picked a lot.
They got a lot of content creators to fill out a form.
And then, you know, as the coaches decide who they want on their, like, you know, it's a draft phase.
So then they're like, look at the list of participants that want to be involved.
And then they just like, they like, oh, I'll pick this person.
I'll pick that through the draft phase.
So on the form, I didn't really sell myself on that form.
That's why I was like, because they're like, oh, you'll find out in like, I think like it was like, you'll find out like it was like last week, like on the 22nd.
They're like, oh, you'll find out on the 22nd if you get picked.
And I was like, all right, cool.
And then so on the form, they were like, what was what's your experience, you know, And I was like, I don't remember.
I was like, I was in stage, I'm slam, but not going to lie, I don't remember anything.
I don't remember how I don't remember anything.
And I don't know.
I, I legitimately forgot everything I learned.
Like I, I, I did not really sell myself.
I was like, I played Zangief on the farm.
And I was like, and then, and then, and then I remember writing.
I remember writing, I don't know how to block.
So, like, you know, that's why I was, like, very surprised because I, you know, I had to be transparent.
I wrote, I don't know how to block.
I don't do defense.
I only do attacks.
So, so, so, so that's why I was like, I was very surprised to get picked because I was, I felt like I wasn't really selling myself.
up as a very good player.
Yeah, I was like full aggression only.
so, you know, I, yeah, I got notified last week that, you know, I'll be in this tournament.
So this tournament starts next week.
I think it's like from the third to the seventh.
But yeah, it was a draft phase.
So I assume like, you know, I assume it's a snake draft because that's usually what the draft phase is like where Each captain picks one from I assume I'm at the I'm at the lowest one like you know the beginner level so Which is understandable you're like but Doki you're you learned street fight.
No, I forgot I legitimately I don't remember anything I don't remember anything I've learned I don't remember any of the controls.
Yeah So so you don't understand I might as well be a beginning.
I forgot everything I've ever learned so yeah like i did say in the past like oh most likely i might not do another tournament like this again because like it was very stressful and i do like um and you know i would rather do it in a new game versus uh going back to street fighter because i like experiencing new games and stuff and i'm also worried that they're i'm also like always worried they'll put me a tier above the beginner because they'll be like oh joki you played like you already did like a techin one and the street fighter one like um like oh we're gonna put you a tear up up beginning and i'm like don't do i'm always worried they'll do that to me um because i already forgot everything i already for uh forgot everything so that's also why i never really i didn't sign up again um and also because you know i wanted to give other people a chance to participate in these types of tournaments like you know the sage i'm sad i felt like you know i'd rather give a chance to be part of
stage i'm slammed like i can't be a beginner forever so and that's why i was always worried about like that you won't put me in the beginner slot um so i never signed up after the last stage i'm slammed but you know capcon contacted me and i was like oh it's something new it's something um it's something new it's something different um i still it's still street fighter but i felt like you know it's a new it's a new tournament and it's organized by Capcom.
And I felt like, you know, wow, Capcom directly reached out to me to sign up.
And it did say it doesn't necessarily mean I'd get picked.
And I, to be fair, I didn't sell myself on the forum too.
So I had, I was like, oh, maybe I won't get picked because I literally was said, like, I don't block.
Like, because I was going to be, I want to be transparent to like whoever drafted me and be like, if they expect me to block, that's on them.
Like, I was so direct about what my skill sets were like if if they expected me to learn that's on them literally justin couldn't even teach me how to block you see so uh no i wanted because i don't you know like i can't disappoint them if i already tell them everything that was wrong with me like you know like they go in knowing what is wrong like so i can't disappoint them because they know they already know like um what's wrong like i'm not like i'm not like jump scaring them they're not blindsiding them with my weaknesses you know like i gotta set the expectations for them so um so yeah i like i have no idea if i was last picked i mean i can't be last picked because i was picked in the end because they did say um they did say like it me signing up for it doesn't mean i'd get picked because they apparently had like a list of participants like list of content creators and stuff and then like the captains themselves were like picking from that list um and you know like the the the
upside of everything is that i'm not participating in the new stage i'm slam for the 2x ko tournament um which is also happening at the same time so like you know half i think like half the people in this capcom one is also participating in the 2x ko tournament so i would assumed they would have they you know they have to split practices and stuff between the two you know between like street fighter and 2x ko because like you know even though it is a fighting game um even though it is a fighting game there's like you know it still plays differently compared like between the two so it's like you know for me the upside of picking me is that i don't have to practice for the other game I don't have to,
I don't have to, like, you know, remember how to play two different games.
I just have to remember how to play one game.
Yeah, so I assume, like, yeah, like, you know, like learning the other game will bleed into Street Fighter as well.
So, you know, conflicting buttons and everything.
And also you guys split the time, too.
So I won't have, like, conflicting stuff to remember.
So, like, I just have to learn one character.
Well, technically relearn a character.
I don't know if I'm going to play Zangief.
I feel like it was very iconic for me to play Zangief.
And then I was talking to Justin.
I messaged Justin.
I mean, like, you want to coach me again?
Sadly, Justin, yeah, we're in first name bases, bro.
That's how tight we are.
I don't know.
It feels weird calling him Mr. Wang.
But sadly, Justin will be traveling next week.
So he won't be available for like another coaching session.
um but he said he would like drop by and like you know yeah that wasler um he would drop by and like see like whenever he is free to like give me like text help but not like actually like help me in game because he will be uh he'll be on a vacation for next week uh but yeah he was telling me that like oh yeah zan geef got nerfed hard so like he he sort of uh he's sort of pretty mid and i was I was like,
no, don't say it like that.
Like, he's like low tier.
He told me he's like, he's pretty low tier in meta right now.
And I'm like, oh, oh, no.
Oh, no, no, no.
Like, nothing can truly nerf the grappler.
I don't, I don't know how he is like low tier.
I don't know how he'd be low tier.
Because I'm like, how the fuck do you?
nerf a grappler and like that's all he has so he just he just has to grab i i don't understand like i i it's crazy i played him and then he gets nerfed um yeah so so i don't know if i will be playing zengi for um for this tournament we'll see how it goes like the coaching stuff starts next week anyway so i do have a lot of time to think about it but i have contacted an additional coach to help me out,
but I'll keep it a surprise until next week's schedule.
I won't reveal who it is until next week's schedule.
But it's going to be, it's going to be pretty fun.
I am very nervous.
Like I said, it has been a while since I've played a fighting game.
my Zangief clips, my Zangief clips, um, because I was like, what the fuck did I do?
And I was rewatching, like, how the fuck did I do that?
I was like, oh my god, this dokey was a different dokey back then, because I was rewatching it, I was like, how the fuck did I, oh my god, how did I have, like, the brain power to do all of this?
I was like, oh my, I was too bad, right now, I'd just be, like button mashing everything.
I was, yeah, I was in the grapple zone.
Yeah, my, yeah, that was a different dokey at that day.
Like, I was re-watching those clips.
I was like, Jesus Christ, I did that.
Oh my God, I was built different.
I really was.
Like, I don't even recognize that dokey when I was watching those clips so I was very very surprised um but yeah I legitimately don't know um how I'm gonna do uh next week uh yeah I'm cooked I maybe I'll surprise everyone who knows Jim thank you with super chat thank you thank you the thing is um I don't know what I'm doing I'm pretty sure last year's Jokey did not know what she was doing either.
But like, thing is, I don't know what I'm doing.
And if I don't know what I'm doing, they don't know what I'm doing.
And I remember that was my strat.
As long as my head is head empty, they can't predict anything.
And that has worked out for me throughout all these tournaments.
It has always worked out for me.
standard dokey technique um yeah to confuse the enemy i have to confuse myself first uh swordsman thank you for the super chat thank you thank you blackfire thank you for the five gifted ships thank you thank you exactly how do you download that witch has no thoughts exactly how can you coach someone against me when everything i do is so unpredictable and doesn't make sense It's like,
you know, they're going to, like, they're supposed to do this move, but I don't know that.
What do you mean I'm supposed to do this move?
I just do whatever feels right.
I'm just reacting.
Like, logically, they're supposed to do this input.
I don't know that.
How am I supposed to know what's logical?
I just do what feels fucking right.
What, what I want to do.
I'm just vibing.
That's my go.
Yeah.
So, yeah, I'm looking forward to...
I've never talked to any of these people before.
That's what I'm also most nervous about.
I've never interacted with any of these people before.
I mean, I've heard of Emily.
Emily Wang.
But other than that, I don't know, Nephew was in a couple of Sage M slams.
So it'll be pretty interesting.
as I've never interacted with these people before.
And I'm also very nervous just because, like, I've never interacted with any other people in this group before.
So, you know how I'm always, like, super nervous with new people.
So I hope it'll be fun.
I hope it'll be really fun.
I hope we'll have a good time bonding with this team.
And, you know, I hope we do okay.
My hope is that we are not last.
that's my goal not last and if anything i hope i win at least one game because i don't know how hard these people are gonna try you know because i remember the last day jam slam um people were like fucking what was that word called they were like analyzing me hard because i for one day i like won all my matches and then they all like hard analyzed my gameplay and shit well i took a one day break and it fucked me over yeah they were laughing against me they would they were like laughing against like my playstyle and stuff and i took a one day break because i was so tired i was so fucking tired oh my food's here yay give me a sec
i have to make sure i don't talk because then they'll be like what the fuck am i talking to um but yeah so so i won't take a one day break again because who would have thought that one day i didn't play didn't practice street fighter everyone like leveled up 20 levels um so i would so i learned from that like i gotta keep grinding there's no apparently there's no breaks in street fighter um but yeah i my goal for this tournament i feel like not last might be too high of an expectation.
I would say I hope I win one game.
That's my goal.
The moment I win one game, I'm happy.
It was stuck for the guy that lost to me.
But like, I'd be happy with just one win through all my matches.
Just because I legitimately forgot everything.
I don't even know what any of the buttons do anymore.
Like I just know if you walk backwards, it blocks.
and that I cannot play on the right oh yeah and then me admitting to everybody that I can't play on the right hand side sort of fucked me over because like I never learned because I never learned how to use how to fight on the right hand side because it's a different because you have to reverse your inputs and I'm like you gotta reverse your inputs and I was like that's weird that's that's like weird oh my god did this person fuck up the the elevator give me a sec guys i gotta mute myself they called me again but on their personal phone
sorry i'm just like i'm checking the messages to see like what they if they said anything oh my god they're trying to do like a voicemail or some shit like excuse me
Oh my god I'm trying to like I mean It's so annoying Because I have the full instructions Because it's very complicated Because you have to use the intercom To access my elevator And it's like you have to use A specific side of the elevator To No it's not say jam slam Apparently it's like similar to say jam slam But this one is fully run by Capcom versus say jam and like you know um i wanted to give this is why i didn't do say i didn't do say jam slam after last time because i want to give people like new players new content creators a chance to participate um wait
what the fuck i called and would have made waited more but there is no parking so i have to please collect i'm collect from the lobby i tried buzzing in when i entered the lift it didn't let me go oh my god you're so i'm giving him a bad review they dropped it at the lobby they just put it in the oh my god rate my order i have to pick you up at the lobby guys I'm actually pretty pissed.
I'm pretty pissed at that.
Tip the courier?
No.
I give him $0.
Yeah, no.
That's just...
That actually makes me mad at the...
Because it's like...
Yeah, they just left my food on the table at the lobby.
Yeah, I have to go downstairs to pick it up.
Because like, the thing is, I had very clear instructions on how to, uh, because like the thing is, all you have to do is just call the intercom.
I let you in.
And then you go on, there's like left or right.
And then I specify which elevator you have to go to.
And then, so like, I think he went on the wrong elevator because there's like left or right.
And I think he went on the other side on the one that he shouldn't have gone to because you have to because then it would like take you to yeah it had like very clear step-by-step instructions because of how complicated it is and um um um and so like but like i rarely have any issues with that like i think like i never had a person i had one time someone leave in the lobby um but just because i didn't put instructions in um and that like this is the first time i had some guy that just left it in the lobby yeah he didn't read um only i'm allowed to not read only um only i'm allowed to not be able to read so i mean
how do i rate the guy i want to rate the person okay there you go
all right i'll go pick up my food i guess i'll be right back guys i'll be right back everybody let's see brb picking up my food i ordered uh i ordered fried rice brb picking up my food with fagra i know i know i i fagra is just so good guys what i i'm sorry i i know the implications I know what I am.
I'm sorry.
I'll be right back.
Holy shit.
There were so many people in the elevator.
I had to wait so long.
It's crazy.
Oh, I think, like, I think it's because everyone's coming home to, like, at this time.
I literally, there was, like, we have, like, a lot of elevators, and even then I had to wait so long to even go downstairs and go up.
Like, even when I was going up, there was, like, there was, like, six people in my elevator obviously.
Gotta go home.
Get home.
Yeah.
Got my friend.
Right.
You have people who camp to leave.
People with their nine to five.
Coming home.
They're using my elevator.
All right.
Did he forgot?
No!
They didn't give me a fork.
I hate it.
You know, grinds my gears when don't get a fork.
I just want utensils.
Hey, when I don't get my...
They get like...
Hey, when like they don't give me utensils and stuff, I have to...
It's like, yeah, forks at home, you guys.
Real metal forks, not just plastic forks.
Real metal forks.
And also, I bought mango juice, too.
Let me take a couple of bites of my food, and then we'll start Batman.
But yeah, I am looking forward to this tournament.
I haven't done a tournament thing in a while.
I'm very nervous.
Like I said, I'm very nervous because I forgot how to play.
I forgot how to play the game.
At least I hope I'm fighting other beginners.
That's all I hope for.
I hope I'm fighting all of the other beginners.
And I hope I don't get absolutely demolished.
Adatra, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
um but yeah anyway let me boot up let me boot up uh batman i technically i do have batman booted up already i was just doing that weird thing where i had to do it pull it up on window and then i was able then i have to like close it and um redo it full screen it's so weird when i try to do it full screen obius is like what the fuck is that I've never seen that game in my life.
So I have to boot it up.
Windowed first before I do it full screen.
Yay, my...
Oh, I smell so good.
I haven't fried rice in a while.
Um, settings.
Full screen.
Yes.
Play.
All right, let me grab pork while I boot this up.
I'll get my pork.
All right.
Rockham City!
Yeah, it's fried rice with crab.
Oh, my God.
That's some good shit right now.
That shit is good.
Also, remember to nominate...
Oh, yeah.
By the way, sorry.
Hashtag add.
I knew I forgot to hashtag add something.
I know this is Batman.
But the streamer awards just...
uh the streamer award nominations just came out and i would love to be nominated for um i would love to be nominated for best marvel rival streamer i would like to be um as someone that has uh talked about marvel rivals a little bit too much it would mean a lot to be nominated for best marvel rival streamer for my ego and for bragging rights
if you guys could stroke my eagle just a little bit more it will mean a lot to be nominated for best marvel rivals i don't i don't i'll not win i just like to be on the list you know thank you so much it really does mean a lot guys um for the ego yeah
ordered oh shit it's leaking the this is where i don't know this is where the beef carpaccio i also ordered beef carpaccio you know like some pho places by the way this is like um this is where i'm a pho place but you know how like some pho places have beef carpaccio um i don't know if it's for the Krabatio.
Order that, dude.
I'm a beef Krabatio.
I didn't eat lunch today, so I'm extra hungry.
Ooh, Miss Fancy.
Ooh, la-la.
That's right.
Oh, it's not for the beef Krabatio.
Hmm.
Rillow me this, Batman.
This is for the fried rice.
Put this on.
Let me...
this in fried rice real quick the soy sauce it's gonna use it all fuck it i don't want to like keep it and then throw this away thank god this is a controller game i can chill with it i just recently cleaned my keyboard too so i don't want to get dirty all right all right i'm ready i'll just get my controller dirty Wait,
no.
I don't want to exit.
I want to start my game.
Alright.
I'm ready.
I already forgot, like, half the controls.
Other than, like, you know the one control I do remember in this game?
The one thing I remember.
Boom, boom, boom!
Random bullshit!
Oh.
Can't see me!
Veteran!
Where am I?
That's a key, right?
The most important control in this game.
Do you know you have to play Mama Rise roughly 11% of the time?
The game has been released!
Jesus Christ!
Pretty boy, thank you for the super chat, thank you.
Thank you.
Wait, I'm... Wait, it's working.
Oh my god, it's working, guys.
It's working.
Where did it come from?
Who keeps throwing these batterans at this direction?
If only I know how to look up.
Oh no, it's...
Trust the plan.
Trust the random bullshit plan.
Oh my god, it killed somebody.
I heard the...
nuclear bomb where could he go this is where this is where your taxpayer money goes to it's a batman batter this is where 80 of gotham's taxes go to i make it eat while do this
let me know when you're dead guys what
Where did he come from?
You sure he came from where?
What happened?
Oh shit, really?
Oh, one of them is dead.
Oh shit.
The double nukes.
Yeah, the tactics go to assist.
This is where the tax tucks go to.
Alright.
Okay, he's...
One of them's dead.
Oh, that guy's dead.
Okay, last guy.
Come on.
You're the last one.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Ooh.
How do I...
I'm sure it came from over there.
Ooh.
There we go.
We did it.
It was just that easy.
Oh wait, it's not even...
Oh my god.
I had to go there.
Oh my god, I thought this was the place.
I didn't realize it took me like so far away.
Was this not the place?
No, it is, right?
This is where Mr. Freeze lives, right?
This has to be where he lives.
Alright, there you go.
Okay, it is.
Okay, thank God.
I was gonna be like, there's no way.
1R.A.
1RT.
1.
What is that?
Oh, here.
Oh, it is the police station.
Okay, I was got a little worried.
I was like, wait, am I not supposed to be here?
I guess it's under, right?
There's like a garage door.
Where would the garage be?
I guess here, right?
Oh, yeah, it is.
Uh...
It was this, but how do I use it?
There you go.
Not enough?
What the fuck?
It's not enough.
Is there something else I'm missing?
Why is it not powering up?
Oh my god, a stupid payphone.
Alright, hello.
oh
battles hardly salvation you've been killing them that's a question of perspective for
life there's no way gotham rent is this good if you hurt them zeds i will hunt you down there's no way living in gotham is like worth it i i just don't understand
it's so low fucking Christ and I kill these piggies my wife kills them who cares this is a robin job not a Batman job I swear to you if rent is not ten dollars why the fuck am I living here like ten dollars a year
this is a robin job not a Batman job I should be outsourcing to my children because all I'm gonna say I'm gonna say like what's the point of having of adopting all these orphans if I can't use them how can I exploit these children.
Like...
True.
Jesus.
Alright, answering the... Oh my god!
Whatever.
Do I actually have to do it?
Jesus Christ.
I answered one random phone call and then it's like, you'll die in seven days.
like i have like 20 robins and none of them could take this job like none of them
at this point where is where is commissioner jordan where is commissioner gordon what's the point of having cops i'm pretty sure a cop would be there
all right oh i hear it ring ring ring ring a ding ding hey guys
ring a ding ding oh that was a unfortunate casualty all right give me a sec i gotta answer this call i can do this later
i have so many enemies i can't keep up bro
oh just like me
i'm trying to trace it
Look, his lore was so important.
It was so interesting, guys.
I was like, oh my god, I can relate so much to him.
Oh.
That's my bad.
It was just so interesting learning about him.
All right.
I leveled up.
I did my job.
All right, guys, what do I upgrade?
Oh well A man just We don't know that He said If I answer a telephone He won't kill a guy And I did answer the telephone I did do it Was there bullet armor?
Is that ballistic armor?
Guess we don't know As long as we don't see him kill the hostage He could be fine Yeah we'll get ballistic armor And then next we'll get We'll get special combo next.
Wait, it's Bat Swarm.
What's Bat Swarm?
Causing a swarm of bats?
Jesus Christ.
Alright, let's just go back to...
Back to Mr. Freeze.
Look, you are just a grunt.
You're not that important.
Wee.
I don't remember where the police Is that the police station over there?
Well, it's too bad I didn't listen to him.
Guys, I don't know where he is, guys.
It's so unfortunate.
Really?
Where?
Oh, there you go.
I'm at the police station now.
Alright.
See if I can remember how to do this again.
Oh, yeah, I have to run and...
Was it run and slide?
There you go.
If I hack this radio, I'll be able to listen into all of Penguin's communication.
Alright, I'm gonna hack it in.
I'm in.
The backslide.
Are there any radio stations?
Is there any music stations here?
Unlucky.
Can't jam out.
all right this should be the penguins thing
active intercept engaged there you go i did it it's just that easy i don't know i just want to see if there's a radio station that i could call a ta make sure it stays that way no problem what is this i listen up boss wants this place held tight no one in or out You see one of Joker's crew?
Waste them.
What about Batman?
Yeah, what about Batman?
Just like that?
What?
That's fucked up, bro.
I'm just chilling.
Trying to chill.
What does it look like?
How do I know?
So how will we know when we find him?
What the fuck?
Yeah, rude.
There's nothing here.
What's the point of being here?
here anyway no idea all i know is penguin wants it good enough for me fuck you know what to fuck we don't need a self this wait unless where does this go oh oh my god it's a stupid riddle me this fuck that oh shit what the fuck so far i was i was not expecting that i Okay,
okay, I didn't expect to get fucking I did not expect to get fucking point-blank shot Okay, open Riddles need this Batman
Can't shut down when I'm in the events I'm in your wise penguin He's making you look like fool.
All right, doing what I do best.
Veteran!
That's right.
Are you, though?
Are you sure of it?
I'm sure it came from over there.
How sure are you?
Guess not sure enough.
That's fucking right.
This way!
He went this way!
There's no way it can...
Keep working.
Yeah, it does.
Oh, shit.
Okay, it's not working anymore.
Wee!
Oh, my God.
It's not working.
It's actually not working.
Look at it.
It's okay.
They don't know.
They're so confused.
Watch this.
Wait.
Come on.
Oh, no, he's not close enough.
I'm just gonna...
Wee!
Ha!
Penguins keep in track of his head.
He'll know each time I take someone out, I need to move quickly.
Oh, God.
Everyone, get your answers over it!
You're not getting past me again!
Ha!
He's dead.
That's right.
Oh, I'm dead!
Ha!
Someone cut the mask off his face.
I thought he's talking about the guy I killed.
I was like, oh, no, it was me.
Oh, he's talking about me.
I'm dead.
Who would have thought?
Joker's crew are still outside.
I thought he's talking about the guy killed.
No problem.
Yep, I'm dead.
Listen up.
Boss wants this place held tight.
No one in or out.
You see why Joker's crew waste them.
he's dead it's me just like that all right let's just go this way i feel like the random bullshit did more work did more work than me actually playing the game
all right let's see what is freezing doing anyway no idea all i know is penguin wants it all right let me hang down And go.
Yoink!
Gotcha now!
Penguins keeping track of his crew using heartbeat markers.
He'll know each time I take someone out.
I need to move quickly.
I'll never know I'm here.
And then...
Where are you?
Bop!
See?
It was so quick, guys.
Don't never expect this.
That's right.
And another one.
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck.
How did they know?
How did they find out?
Over here.
Oh, my God.
They keep looking up.
How do they know how to look up?
That's illegal.
Oh, my God.
That actually is.
They're not supposed to know if I keep going back and forth.
I know what you're doing, and it ain't gonna work.
Oh, yeah, you can't catch me.
I'm so fucking fast.
Whoooooo!
Baa!
There's no way he lives from that.
I literally, like, slam-dunked him with my entire body.
This ain't happening.
I've got another man down over here.
Yeah?
Get out of here.
That's right.
You ain't shotgunning shit!
Please, I get out of here.
Oh, interrogate?
All right, tell me everything you know.
He's in the museum.
Penguin's got him.
No, I'm sorry, Mr. Cobblepot.
He made me tell him.
That's right.
Snitches get stitches.
I'm here to teach you that.
I'm like, I won't do anything.
You tell me everything, except I'll give you a concussion.
All right, rescue him.
Okay, rescue Mr. Freeze from...
Wait, Penguin has Mr. Freeze?
Why won't he just freeze him?
Is he stupid?
That doesn't sound good.
Yeah, that's right.
I gotta teach him that Snitches get stitches.
He thinks he's playing Spider-Man.
It's like I'm Mad Bat.
Anything cool here?
Anything neat?
Why is there like...
Oh, is this like the autopsy area in the police station?
What kind of fucking police station is this?
Holy shit.
I guess I gotta leave.
The Gotham.
Yeah, I'm like wondering.
Oh my god.
Wait, the vents.
The vents won't let me through.
Yeah, Mr. Freeze stupid.
Why don't you just freeze him?
God, stupid riddle me this.
I'm gonna riddle me this fast.
Man.
Is there anything interesting here?
Guys, am I missing anything here?
Like, it's a police station.
Like, why does the Gothen...
Why... How does the Gothen police have this much budget for anything with the stuff they do?
Like, with the stuff they... Sorry, let me rephrase that.
With the stuff they don't do.
I feel like... I feel like I should cut the police.
budget Alfred hello sir there were complications penguin has got his hands on freeze and trapped me in the GCPD building oh yeah forgot Joker gave me super aids reminding me Alfred I'm in a police building cobblepots obviously bribed some official into giving him the lock codes for the municipal structures I'm downloading the unlock codes right now
I assume that's the other side.
When I was, like, in this area, I was like, what the fuck is the point of being here?
Yeah, I knew it.
Makes sense.
Okay.
Oops.
Am I not doing it?
Oh, I have to press R2.
What the fuck?
How the...
Um, excuse me.
Yeah.
Am I not doing it correctly?
Rotate so you find the point at which the letters stop.
Yeah, I'm rotating.
The other one, the other side isn't doing anything.
Oh!
Sorry, the right agnologue stick.
There we go.
I forgot about the right side.
I only read 50%.
Thank you, the magenta soup, but thank you, thank you.
Riddle me this, riddle me that was red and black and smack.
Why?
Alright.
That's easy.
After I figure out how to read the last 50% of that instruction.
Sorry, my right side of the brain doesn't work as well as my left.
Whoa, shit.
That sounds very bad.
Alright.
Yeah, but we don't care about that.
You're just goons.
You're replaceable.
And your point is, well, it's just you live
where you die, son.
And then you super chat think you think, yeah, I played Arkham Asylum.
That's right.
And now I leave.
Fuck that guy in particular.
Oh, no.
Am I dead?
Oh, I'm okay.
Bubblepot has made his move.
Leave them to it.
It will be interesting to witness how things progress as we approach Protocol 10.
Affirmative.
83, continue your patrol.
Out.
That's right.
Not a good day for that one guy.
Sucker Punch Simpson leaves.
That's right, I'm Batman.
Well, could have been any one of them.
I guess but so is the black mask Hell cutting the city in two What is this new mission that they kept telling me Yeah The command is 85 I have visual on the
team Leave Keshe and his pathetic team to die Oh shit I'll switch that to Nightwing
Don't worry Nightwing can handle that Wait wait for what for two face to give the order that's crime alley where oh my gosh crime alley let's go right here finally i'm gonna relive his trauma this is where my parents die i don't care what you did out there oh my god this is actually where his parents died oh my god it was right here we're here to relive trauma let's go batman how does it feel wayne to stand on the very stones that ran with your parents yeah do you feel sad full of rage or does that outfit help bury your feelings we found a crime alley we can we finished this game oh you are a truly extraordinary specimen what the fuck to breaking you
holy shit it will end where it be oh my god that's so up oh he goes strange is a little bit fucked up wait i messed up he's the one that did that
i feel like someone please save me and batman's like
that guy's okay i'm trauma bonding right now and I'm experiencing trauma.
Bro, yeah, the political prisoner got like, he got waived.
Alright, we did it.
We paid respect, we gave him trauma.
We relived trauma.
Mission accomplished.
Joki, what about the prisoner?
What prisoner?
What do you mean, prisoner?
I did what I came for.
Is it here?
Where is it here?
Where is it?
Okay, it's so far.
I'll join Penguin.
Look, maybe he shouldn't have fucking visited crime alley.
That's his own fault.
why was he in crime alley it's like going to like it's like thinking that crime wouldn't fucking appear in crime alley like is he stupid yeah wait what did he expect to happen exactly maybe the freaking bad hello oh my god that's right my bat now
Bro, what the fuck?
Batman!
Bro, what the fuck did I do there?
Okay, that was crazy.
That was a crazy-ass move.
Like, I- Bro, if my fucking fist does nuclear bomb shit, make nuclear bomb sound effects, I feel like...
I just put- I literally put him in a coma at that point.
Yeah, that guy...
guy's dead dead there's no way oh my god this fish should not do any damage to me look at the armor i have it was named after john crime absolutely thank you for the super chat thank you thank you i'm just saying if my punch breaks the goddamn sound barrier he's not alive anymore I made him brain dead at that point.
His fucking fist literally just broke the sound barrier.
I opened this door with decryptor.
I'm in.
Just use the door.
This is Penguin's turf, you freak.
I'm gonna cut you up in the tiny piece.
Oh yeah?
Watch this.
Wait what?
Hold...
Oh.
Oh shit, sorry, I'm trying.
I was like...
What?
Am I not...
Fuck this.
I've had enough.
I don't need a dodge.
I try... I try to follow the rules.
But I realized...
Following the rules is for pussies.
The old reliable.
All visitors must be searched as part of our ongoing commitment to keep you safe and protect the unique connection we have on display.
All visitors should be sure to check out our...
Attraction.
Danger for the deep.
In the aquatic observations...
Huh?
What the fuck do I do?
Oh, all right.
I see.
One-way glass.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, it's like his calling card.
He has a penguin.
Okay.
Guess I have to start hacking.
I don't think I want you breaking into my little old Batman Something's blocking communication back to the bad cave Penguin must be using military grade communication disruptors The only way to crack this security is to destroy them Oh okay Where's the jammer
Disable penguins destroy okay I gotta find Three hostile, three unarmed.
Okay, how do I...
Why can't I just break this?
I'll never get past the security.
I should head back outside.
Oh, it's outside.
Okay.
It's outside.
Alright, that's good to know.
I was gonna beat the shit out of that computer.
42.
It's this way.
All you need to know Where the fuck is the jam, man?
Hey, are you a bad person?
He's unarmed, so I couldn't tell.
Give me a sec.
I just walked up like, hey, buddy.
There you go.
You know what?
Wait, this is just easier.
Get out of here.
That's right.
I don't care if you're unarmed.
Why are you...
Is that the Jammer over there?
What is that?
Oh, that's a security camera.
Whoops.
How the fuck is it?
Down here?
Where the fuck is this stupid-ass Jammer?
Where are my- what are my, like, 20 robins doing anyway?
You don't need to get it.
Oh my god, it was up here this entire time.
time.
Now that I think about it, what the fuck are they doing?
Oh my god, really need this.
Oh, it's right here.
Guarded by 20 security guards.
I wonder why I never noticed that.
Taking care of Gotham.
Where?
I'm literally here in Gotham City.
I do not see it.
I do not hear anything about them.
Okay.
Oh, that's not good.
Alright.
That's fucking right.
Get out of here.
Boom!
That's right.
You know what?
Yeah.
Get this out.
The best way to...
The best way to destroy a jammer three to shut it down has three terminals wait that's terminal one oh they're all here that's cool I was gonna say three terminals terminals where could it be time to fist the machine jammer down I should look for more all right next one is this way one of the jammer signals disappeared sorry mr.
Okay, now that I know that the jammers are guarded by 20 security guards, it's a lot easier.
Okay, I was like, I thought it'd be like, you know, more hidden, but now that I know, it's really 20 people.
There you go, I see them.
He's a collector.
He's got things you've never heard of.
And that's the fact.
Oh, shit!
It's fine.
On you.
Whoops.
Yes, it wasn't on you.
Smoke bomb!
Where are you?
There you are.
That's fucking right.
Wait, where's he?
Oh, shit, wait.
Wait, what?
Let me fist this real quick.
Then I give me a sec.
Just let me...
No!
No, no, no, no!
Get out of here!
Alright.
Interrupting a good fisting.
Alright, nice.
Gotta let me finish, bro.
I didn't claw.
That's not bro behavior.
We've only just managed to get below ground.
Just set
it.
It's downstairs, okay.
Sounds like Penguin's final jammer was activated somewhere underneath Arkham City.
Okay, it's in the sewers.
Jesus, pressure's so far.
What's this?
Oh, yeah, we don't need a dive bomb.
Oh, I have to level it up.
Do we want...
Do we want special combo boost, right?
All special combo moves will be available after...
Yeah, we should get that.
I'm just here to beat up people.
Why doesn't he just make, like, non-lethal gun?
I ain't got a ping-pong gun.
I feel that.
I just need a batter-ons.
No, batter-ons are more lethal than a gun.
That's sharp as fuck.
Do you think about it?
Like this way.
I didn't think about it.
The clue was in the name.
Oh, shit!
What the fuck?
Where did it come from?
All right, I'm leaving.
Smoke bomb!
Yeah, figure out where the fuck this...
Where is the last...
Okay, it's down here.
Oh my gosh, I have to be up here.
That sucks.
Is it here?
This way.
Wait, is it?
What the fuck is it?
It says underground.
It's not this way.
Didn't get to be in Arkham City?
Didn't Batman smash that car of his into him back at the asylum?
Where is the entrance?
Don't shoot!
I was just at it?
Here?
Is somewhere here?
No, it goes...
32?
Is it above me?
There's a subway?
The fuck's the subway entrance?
Oh, there's the subway.
There it is.
But the gate is because the gate was closed, guys.
Never don't jump the gates.
Can I do that?
It never said anything about working on the ground.
Yeah, they work.
Oh, you guys know.
Since one of you been all about reading anyway.
I read horn don't count screw you about me isn't he
Hey guys
Yeah They're like how long was he there?
There you go See there's a jammer right here Oh, it's the goddamn.
I'm not doing the real shit that guy's like I'm not enabling his behavior
It's not for me.
Oh, is that like cat women's?
You guys taking the subway too?
It's over here What?
Oh, what is that?
Explode!
Oops.
Wrong one.
Oh, why won't it explode?
Oh, there we go.
I just pressed it right.
Oh my god, guess how well do your stupid Ridley shit.
I forgot you had to hold left and then hold left button and then right button.
Where else do we go?
I guess we go downstairs?
Hello, hello!
I'm in your vents.
With me, Batman!
Oh my god, goddamn fucking Riddler.
I want to know how much money he spent in doing this.
Like, he's just doing it for the fun of it.
He's just putting trophies everywhere.
That's it.
He's not even committing any crime.
He's just being very annoying.
Yeah.
This panel is protected using Tiger encryption protocols.
I can't decrypt it without access to the master control program strange uses.
All right.
I gotta get to the master control panel then.
Oh, awesome.
Chat.
Fix that real quick.
He's fixing chat real quick.
Because I can't see chat.
He just wants you to have fun.
The only crime he's committing is just trespassing.
What is this?
Where am I now?
What?
whether you're this way what is it this way yeah it is my god it's an actual maze can't be it is look again he looks big right he's gray this post has got to be over a hundred years old how can it be the same guy and even if it was how did penguin get it i don't know but i'm sure it is It's even got a name.
Solomon Grundy?
That's the stupidest name I've ever heard.
That's the thing you can hear in the museum.
You know, Solomon Grundy born under my name.
But he's in this game?
You may be right.
Oh shit.
Like all the classics are here.
Hey guys.
Breaking another sound wave.
I love Solomon.
Oh, he's Solomon Grundy is pretty is a pretty silly character I think the only thing I know but honestly the only thing I know much about I don't know if like it's very accurate but the only thing I know about Solomon Grundy is from the Justice League show
Oh, it's just a reference.
Oh, it's unlucky Good I always wanted a chance to go up against that freak Oh, and also injustice too the injustice mobile game not that Not the flood, not the consulate.
Kill Batman, drag this thing to Joker, turn it on, and go back to Cobble Pot as heroes.
What?
Just like that.
Kill Batman.
Yeah, it can't be that hard, right?
He just got, just kill Batman.
He's nothing.
If that disruptor stops working, Batman will be free to stroll right into my lovely museum.
And if you let that happen, I'll let you all get to see what I'm keeping up with.
to the iceberg lounge.
Yoink!
Got you now.
Got you nose.
Oh, shit.
Wait, how do you know?
Alright.
I love breaking the sound barrier.
Yeah, which way?
Pop!
That's right.
Round of bullshit!
Can your gun hide from this?
Alright.
The only counter, the gun.
That's the last guy.
Let us start fisting.
Who the fuck cares about the grapple?
Why the fuck did I upgrade the grappling gun disarm when I literally have a battered?
I feel like I feel like battered is so much easier.
It works.
If it works, it works.
I should be able to get into the museum now.
How do I get out of here?
Wait, how do I get out of here?
I don't remember how I got here.
I'm so lost.
Um...
I should be allowed to just break through that glass, right?
I think it was this way.
I just gotta backtrack my way back.
Okay.
Oh, it was this way.
Okay, there you go.
It was an event.
This is... Oh, my God.
Oh, I thought I broke the game.
Let's do this little hole.
That's expensive glass.
And I'm literally motherfucking Bruce Wayne!
Nothing is expensive.
What the hell is happening down there?
Hello?
Is someone gonna answer me?
I'll give you one simple task.
Oh, don't worry.
I definitely did.
I can literally write a paycheck to solve all my problems.
Oh, hey.
Really need this?
Like, whoops, property damage?
That's alright.
Here's $8 million.
What does Wayne Industry do anyway?
Wait, now that I think about it, what the fuck does Wayne Industry even make?
Every...
everything like i never really realized like what the fuck does wayne industry do they just make money private equity on you know stuff wait does that mean he sells weapons to like the middle east like i'm
Do you think Batboose Wayne is a really bad person?
Isn't that what Iron Man did?
I remember the first Iron Man movie.
Like Tony Stark used to sell weapons.
In war.
Yeah, just like Stark.
Isn't that what fucking Tony Stark did?
And then he got kidnapped.
I was like, wait.
Wait, this is actually a really bad thing.
Just like art.
Yeah, that's that's what Tony Stark did.
Is that what Bruce Wayne do does too?
It's like who the fuck am I sell who the fuck is Bruce Wayne selling his weapons to?
Yeah, Tony Stark was an asshole.
Oh, just tech.
Okay, but like what kind of tech though?
Wait, that's a helicopter.
Is that a bad helicopter?
a good hello oh i guess we'll never know
all right it's five zero visual on target i repeat we have lost sight of that
i don't know it could feel like he's just chilling the person at the helicopter it's like who the fuck does wane industry even sells like Sell his their tech.
I think it's bio.
That does not make it any better.
Bioterism is not a good thing.
Jesus Christ.
What the
fuck?
Who did that?
Oh, hey.
guys.
Did not mean to kill you, but we were just there.
We were there at the wrong time.
That what?
Tamer down in sector one.
This ain't over.
No way.
Oh, it's here.
Hey guys.
No.
There we go.
Taylor here.
Get out of here.
Get your ass out of here.
Oh my god, there's so many things going on in my screen.
That's fucking right.
I know all the kung fu.
Wait, can I just leave?
Wait.
Oh, I have to secure the area.
I was like, can I just like walk away?
I just leave?
That's fucking right.
Get out of here.
I just opened the door.
Yeah.
Wait, voicemail?
Send me a voicemail?
What?
That's it?
What the fuck does he mean by that?
As a wise man once said, Batman doesn't kill.
But you never know when he plans to start, do you?
Thank you for the Super chat.
Thank you.
I saw a comic panel from Injustice.
And then it was like the panel where Super I was about to kill Joker.
And he was like, Bruce, not now.
And the Joker was like, Bruce.
But he's like about to fucking die.
And he's like, oh my god, I did it.
I finally know his secret identity.
It's soon.
He's like, I'm just about to die.
But oh my God I fight figuring it out it's Bruce Wayne
I thought he would let me crash through that window I guess not
whoa what the fuck over 65 million years ago all visitors with a valid ticket are confessing Hello?
Oh, it was just acting.
Okay.
I was gonna be like, what the fuck?
Is this Jurassic Park now?
I haven't had jumpscares.
I'm so confused.
What is he doing?
Weeeeee!
Man, he's here!
Oh shit!
Oh my, I'm trying to...
What the fuck?
Stop!
What the fuck am I using?
Oh, explosive jet!
Wait, that's even better than batter ends.
Wait, I didn't do that!
Explosive jet!
That's right!
$20 million, God!
But worth it!
Does this kill?
I can't tell.
I don't think it does.
I think it just does.
But it's so silly.
Okay, let's get this over here.
Alright, where are you?
We gotta get this over with.
I mean, I can...
Alright.
$20 million gone from Wayne Industries.
What's that?
Hello?
What the fuck?
Oh, did she... is it like...
Oh my god, wait, his collection is people!
He's like the collector!
Oh, is this like one of Joker's goons?
Man, you look taxidermy, I'll just leave.
I don't live!
Is that the ventriloquist?
I assume that's one of the ventriloquists, right?
What's over there?
Oops.
Yeah, Scarface, yeah.
Wait, is she alive?
Oh, wait, no, she's not alive.
She's dead.
Wait, what's up?
Oh, oh, oh, yeah, I saved him.
I was like, wait, what the fuck?
He's just standing there.
I don't think she's alive.
No, she's definitely dead.
Wait, is she actually alive?
Why is she just standing there?
This would be the jewel in my collection.
That's me.
How do you check her vitals?
I can only scan her.
Oh, is she just meditating?
Oh, I thought she'd be like, taxidermeter.
Oh, yeah, she is alive.
She's moving.
You're safe for now.
I did it.
I'm a hero.
You may want to hold off on thanking him until after you've answered my question who are you sorry man I'm a cop Gordon's innocent here I'm from the 13th precinct part of the strike team been in here since the beginning if Gordon sent you you'll know the code oh yeah yeah he said oh man what was it hmm the code now hmm it's racist he said to tell you the code is Sarah You're safe,
officer.
It's Jones, Batman.
Elvis Jones.
Gordon always said he planned on sending your team in.
He wanted to know what was going on.
Friendly, non-lethal explosions.
Think of this reach out.
Absolutely, thank you.
Hopefully, you still are.
It's like sea stills.
Invincible.
Every time he teleports, it costs like $500,000 to taxpayer your money.
I'll find them.
Elvis is alive.
Okay, rescue Mr. or freeze from penguin rescue remaining undercover is that like optional oh Jesus Christ
okay I hope that's optional
it's required I mean he wouldn't know we could just hire more police officers we don't I mean, they don't even do most of the work in Gotham anyway.
I do most of the work in this goddamn city.
So that's the scanner.
We gotta disable it somewhere.
New recruits this way?
Like, I don't think it makes much of a difference.
In Gotham City, if they're missing one or two more cops.
What?
A remote controlled battery can hit switches that are out of reach.
Like, where do I- oh, it's up here.
I was gonna say, where do I- fuck do I throw it?
I don't remember how to fucking control this.
Okay.
Alright, it's this way.
First try.
Let her go.
Oh, there's...
Oh, no, that's cute.
It's a family portrait.
Before his parents, I guess, like, kill themselves.
Is that cute?
The gladiator pit.
Help me?
I wouldn't do that if I was you.
Show him what we got.
Bro, how did he get so many of the cops?
You're here for the cops.
The ice man.
Yay, one less to save.
Oh my god, it's daddy Davido.
I was only here for freeze and the hostages.
But now I'm taking you down too.
Oh, aren't you scary?
out am I really
listen I'm what you might call a collector if someone wants it or I don't think I've got it and if I don't have it I'll get it not really a collector when you don't have a Batman with your name on it just waiting to be built and as luck would have it here you are standing just where i want you i am the prize jewel of his collection out he can't have what he'll know can't have what he'll what we've always won in boy and give up nicely you're not giving orders here anymore cobblepot i was open you'd say that look around you this horrible bunch of psychopaths are all begging to join up with me but unfortunately for them i only i'm like the one that got away and today best means whoever can kill you come on out lads it's initiation time that jesus christ okay i did not oh my god i don't have i don't know if i have enough batter ass for this i am holy fuck okay that's a lot of people I did not expect like,
you know, I thought it'd be like six, but then he literally sent out like 50 people.
I'm, I'm in the, I'm actually in the pit right now.
Jesus Christ.
Thank God they're like, they're like level one.
They're like level one mob mobster.
And I'm the level 100 crime boss.
All right, oh no, I have a concussion right now from the hammer.
Nice.
Hey, hey, hey.
I'm trying to give this guy a concussion.
He said this is my little corner.
Get out of here.
You weren't supposed to do that, Batman.
You should have sent a real art.
You should have sent 80 men instead.
You're forcing me to bring out the big guys.
Oh, shit.
What's that?
Oh, my God.
He really loves his right eye.
He was very lonely in that cell.
Oh, it doesn't look happy to see you, Batman.
What the...
Look, he was very lonely.
Is that Bane?
Wait.
Holy shit.
What the fuck am I doing?
Titan smash!
Okay.
Wait, I can level up.
Give me a sec, guys.
Free flow focus.
When achieving a combo?
Okay, that's way too much.
Chee.
Maybe I should...
I feel like I should use it on...
Oh, shit.
Sonic batter.
No, that doesn't matter.
Maybe armor?
Shockwave attack?
Should I do more armor?
You should do more armor.
We'll do the free flow later.
Oh my god, he broke his goddamn legs.
Jesus.
Oh my god, there's too many fucking guys around us.
I'm just trying to get away from all these.
Alright.
Oh, yoink.
Yoink.
Can't get me.
Bro, I'm trying to do my own fight here with this goddamn team.
Titan right now.
Bro, you could be a gymnast.
A gymnast.
Yeah.
I did it.
I found Penguin.
And Mr. Freeze.
Not yet.
The situation is worse than I thought.
Penguin has a supply of the Titan formula.
What?
Hey, welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
What's going on here?
Your SIDS bio-readings are spiking.
Nice of you to join us, Oracle.
Alfred, bring Barbara up to speed.
Of course.
I'll be in touch.
Oracle.
Am I going to talk to any of the Robins?
Like, do they exist in this Earth?
We've been solo this entire time.
Oh, is she, is she like after the Joker broke her legs?
Yeah, that is.
But that all ended when Joker shot her through the spine.
That comic book, if anyone ever seen the, because that's the infamous, they made an animated, I know they made an animated version of the comic series of where the Joker shot her in the spine.
It's so fucked up.
The original comic, that killing joke, yeah.
the killing joke is like it's like such a fucked up um um comic series i remember because like the joker wanted to do did a lot of really fucked up shit in there yeah it's really messed up but it's also like a classic because that's really like the most iconic uh cover art cover art came from with him with the camera i never watched the animated adaptation but i know the i've read the original comic series the the comic series of it oh it's here let's see where the fuck is the door ow
I'm surprised I'm surprised that it's bad because it's like um okay there's oh god okay where's the hole I gotta find the hole oh there it is um just because the killing joke is so iconic where
there's a hole there's a goal
i'm out of here all
right time to hack
i'm gonna spend another million dollars on the satellite that helps me with the hacking
and jesus christ there's so many tools to use This is this.
Oh.
Send it back down, please.
What the fuck?
Wait, how do I access this?
Oh, I have to stand here.
Oh, fuck, oh.
Now what?
Oh.
What?
Oh, am I supposed to blow that up?
I didn't realize that was drywall.
I'll repeat my, that's my tag, my graffiti tag right here.
Oh, bardo.
Okay.
I mean, what's that?
I can't really.
Okay, really want this.
My gang sign.
This is Batman territory.
Okay.
I didn't suppose to do anything here.
I already hacked that, though.
So the first half of the movie is based on a different comic, and it's not great to put it like Lee.
The second half is actually pretty good.
I would assume the second half is better just because it's based off the main comic.
Oh, wait.
So thank you for the super chat, Brady.
Thank you, thank you.
Mr. Freeze?
I'm here to save you!
Stay where I can see you, Batman.
You wouldn't believe the fight the old snowman put up.
Still, I got what I wanted.
That's all that matters.
Guys, I have a feeling that I'm not saving any cops today.
Oh.
Goodbye, cop number two.
When you're done in here, feel free to join me in the Iceberg Lounge so I can...
See, I told you it was optional.
I told you the cops were optional, guys.
They just happened to be dead, too.
Oh, shit.
Wait, you're alive?
Oh.
Is he gonna have, what's it called?
Please.
Help.
The ice looks unstable.
He looks like he has frost, but...
It's fine.
Oh!
Oh shit, there's sharks!
Anyone want...
Okay.
Alright.
It was not fine.
Not...
How was I supposed to know there were sharks?
Oh, there's fishes.
I feel like a shark...
Like, how was I supposed to know how a shark would be down there?
Yeah, I thought from, like, frostbite.
Not because I'm shy.
Stay.
Alright.
Alright, now.
The ice looks unstable.
I need to move slowly.
Take my time.
Try to activate this.
How does this work?
Like, how the fuck does this work?
Oh, just move slow, okay.
Well, I've got you.
You might have- we might have to cut your toes, but that's okay.
You should be safe here.
Thank you.
Are you from the 13th precinct?
Where's the rest of your team?
There are two more guys in this room.
Penguin froze them up, then went after me.
I ran and...
Well, I guess you saw what happened.
I'll get them.
You wait here and try to warm up.
Yeah, he definitely has frostbite.
There's no way.
Where?
Oh, there they are.
Wait, is that one of them?
Missed.
Oh.
Slowly.
Slowly, slowly.
Oh shit!
Okay.
That's fine.
Sorry, Batman.
Did I forget to mention my little friend down there?
Me, tiny.
Who does it go?
It could be so useful.
Not me, that's for sure.
He's like a mobile garbage truck.
Whatever I drop in that tank just vanishes.
Where do I have to go?
What is that over there?
I'm gonna go this way.
I don't know what that is over there, but I'm gonna go this way.
Oh, that's it?
What?
I'm not supposed to save these people.
Like, what am I supposed to do?
There's like two guys over there.
I don't know if I can even reach them.
Oh, it's optional?
Fuck yeah, let's go.
I think they're dead anyway.
It should be fine.
If I leave them in the ice, they'll freeze to death.
You kidding me?
Well, like, okay, what does it, how does this benefit me, though?
optional.
We don't know that.
How come it won't let me grapple?
Oh, like this?
Oh, I have to do this.
Oh!
Oh, I see.
Okay.
About to break the ice, though.
Right?
You know what?
I'm so scared.
Oopsie.
I feel like it's for... I feel like it's not for now though.
Because I don't have a raft for this.
Where's the other platform?
Is there another platform?
Yeah, there's no more platforms.
There's this, but I don't even know if I can get there.
Look up?
I just see a stupid Riddler.
I see that.
Let's grab this real quick.
Or is that for later?
Can I actually cut that with a batter end?
Let's find out.
Oh!
I can't!
Nice.
But can I get there?
Well, let me get there, though.
That's right.
Best detective.
I can't grapple to it.
I can pull it.
Okay, that's good to know.
I didn't realize I can pull this.
Alright.
Save him.
I got you.
I feel like he'd be dead already.
he definitely would have frozen by now but like all right that's cool i don't know maybe he's like some fucking super soldier i don't know how you're still alive i should cut off both your arms from prospect
so cold where did penguin get that gun he stole it from mr freeze i'm getting it back
Got you!
Like, I have no idea how you survived this.
What's over here?
Anything interesting here?
Hello?
Wait, what's this?
Where am I?
They're using thermal imaging headsets.
Anyone wearing them will be able to spot me hiding up in the darkness.
Oh.
I don't even know what to do.
Am I supposed to go here?
I thought I was supposed to go to the lounge.
Batman's on the way and the last time I saw him, he didn't look very happy.
He's not getting past me and the boys, sir.
The suit is safe.
Tell the boys there's an extra hundred grand in it for whoever brings him in alive.
Very generous, sir.
Oh, that's a lot of cops.
Listen up.
Penguin wants the bad brought in.
All right.
Smoke bomb.
I'll be back.
That's right.
Can't see shit.
Which way?
You'll never...
Oh, I'm dead.
Okay.
Maybe it wasn't smart for me to go straight in.
All right.
This time I'll stealth it.
Watch this.
Okay,
for real.
Oh, shit.
Okay, give me a sec.
Okay, this is not good.
This is not good.
Oh, my God.
You think I need last me?
Okay.
He doesn't know.
He doesn't know Where could I be?
I don't know Oh
yeah My
Okay I didn't think I could get shot out in the middle of my takedown game This time This time Stealth is not off I figured it out.
Listen to me, Pig.
The only reason you're still alive is so Batman has someone to come and save.
Yeah, when he does, I'm gonna blow his car.
Who's screaming?
That's right.
Who could it be?
What happened to you?
How come you're up there?
Help me!
Help me down!
Oh, they're so confused now.
look at that look how confused they are how's he doing it shut the hell up we need to keep looking or we're all dead we're not scared of you you need this real fat there you go see look at that stealth oh my god oh my god that was an accident stealth all natural stealth Look,
he lost me.
We did it.
They know.
They're almost as confused as Toki.
Thank you for the super chat.
Absolutely.
Thank you.
Kel, thank you for the super chat.
Hey, Toki, I just fell to shit.
Oh, the lava makes me feel better seeing you streaming.
Thanks for everything you did.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I hope the next lab you'll do better, but I'm glad to cheer you up, man.
I think it was Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
But I should see if they have any information on Penguin.
Oh, okay.
I was trying to go back because I forgot to go to the Mr. Freeze lounge.
They never saw it coming.
Pure self-gameplay right there.
You're part of Gordon's strike team.
I've seen your file.
You have?
I mean, yes, sir.
Cabal Pots turned this place into a fortress.
Someone ratted us out.
Me and the boys got grabbed, brought here, and beaten the crap out of.
The other thing you was super chat, the other thing?
Yeah.
There are just two more of you unaccounted for.
There's two more?
Cabal Pots like to take us in there to beat us up somewhere.
Yeah, it's near the Ice Pots lounge.
That's where they are.
That's why I wanted to go first.
This area is so... This map is crazy big.
room no one in or out well what about the little bastard that did this to us i want payback you'll get the rest of the squad and then we get our payback i miss when maps were like this detailed instead of like copy and paste there's so many little references to like um there's so many little references to like bits and parts of other uh like stuff in batman it's really really cool.
I like that.
Oh, I didn't see this.
God fucking!
Get me out of here.
Riddle me this!
Fuck off, Riddle me!
I don't want to riddle me this.
You guys all out of the ice, Batman.
We owe you big.
Hello, Batman.
Can you hear me?
Of course you can.
Thought you'd like a little- Yeah, there's a lot of passion in the level this out.
It's like there's like areas where it's like it's just lore.
There's nothing like um important.
There's no reason to go there.
It's just to explore the lore of the area.
Let's hear him squeal.
Oh shit!
What happened is the sound of an undercover cop having his fingers frozen to sub-zero temperatures.
Oh god.
I wonder what would happen if I take this hammer and- I should stop this.
What do you know?
His whole bloody hand explodes.
Holy fuck, Penguin.
Shoot him already.
I should stop this.
Slowly walks over.
Let's see.
Alright, you should be in here.
Yes.
That's me.
Oh!
Shit!
Oh my god, I thought you were gonna fucking get a monologue!
The weapon is too powerful.
The only person who knows the gun's weakness is Freeze.
What the fuck?
I thought you were gonna monologue!
Okay, so fuck me.
I'm not allowed to go here.
Oh my god, don't fuck off, bro.
Yeah, where's the villain monologue?
He was talking to me!
I need to find a way to disable his gun.
Maybe its maker will have the answer.
Where is his maker?
I don't see anyone.
I don't see Mr. Freeze anywhere.
Where'd they put him?
Oh, he's dead, dead.
I assume like he's not here.
Oh, fuck.
I should go find trees.
See if he knows how to defeat his own weapon.
Yeah, but...
Alright, goodbye.
Like, is it not here?
Oh, wait.
There's a...
There's like a little opening here.
Wait.
Do you think he's on the other...
Is he on the other side?
side of that?
Like, I just left the room.
I was just like, alright, see ya.
I'm just like, you got this.
The weapon is too powerful.
Yeah, like, there's something here.
There's a room here.
I didn't access that room.
Is it not through here?
I haven't gone to yet?
Oh my god, it's literally called the fucking torture chamber.
Oh, here!
Oh, it's here!
Okay.
It's the right side.
That's crazy.
That's just called the torture chamber.
Whoops.
I went a little too fast.
Cookies.
It's nice that he refreezed the ice for me, though.
Okay.
It's the goon room tab.
Bitch.
Bro, should we stop it?
Nah.
He's just a fucking nerd.
What the fuck did he do?
Oh my god he got bad Let's get that bad out of here Get out of here That's right Wait what the fuck is BX Oh shit that's what BX is That's right Time for a beat down.
That's right.
You think I'm gonna stop?
Okay, you're right.
Maybe I won't.
You know what I can do, though?
Wait, what?
Alright, get this bat out of here.
What?
There we go.
Oh, you don't need that arm no more.
I bet being a doctor in Gotham City?
It pays you so fucking well.
Gamers don't read.
Who needs reading when I'm a millionaire?
Yeah, that arm is gone.
We gotta cut it.
We might as well just cut that arm.
Wait, was Batman's dad a doctor?
No wonder he fucking died in crime alley.
Wait, there's No way, his dad's a doctor and he was a billionaire.
Oh,
that's fuck.
Wait, Batman's dad was a doctor?
That's when my chat died.
Let me fix that.
I got a tab out.
It's like not enough memory to open this.
Oh my god, no wonder.
He's, it's literally like a get- rich quick
my friend sent me this i tabbed out i saw had discord messages and i sent this picture
yeah i could never escape them i could never escape mega star me
I see him.
Oh my god.
He like chose like...
Bruce's dad chose like the perfect place to live.
Literally infinite money glitch.
Holy shit.
Who's that?
Wait, he's still alive.
Is that Mr. Freeze?
Holy shit, you okay, bro?
Oh my god, wait, that's fucked.
He put him in, like, fucking Bahamas.
What happened to you?
Wait, let me read this first before I help you.
Okay, well, how can I...
Oh, wait, here.
Well, I got you, bro.
Oh, sorry.
That's hacking.
Oh, wait.
I can listen to the radio.
Bro,
it's my...
I got...
Bro, it's my 10-minute break.
Yeah.
Nice, I gotta listen to my favorite radio station, guys.
How do I get out of here?
Okay, wait.
I'm trying to figure out how to get out of the room.
All I can do is just listen to the radio.
I'm decoding the radio station.
Give me a sec.
Okay, there we go.
All right, explosives, yeah Oh shit, what the fuck?
Okay, guess I don't need it
I shall slice you into pieces.
It's okay.
I have this
Oh, what the fuck
Okay, there's like so many Oh my god.
He has a knife.
Oh god.
I don't even know if I'm doing anything to him.
It's just...
Oh shit!
Yeah, I'm glad Goon number four helped me out.
Oh yeah, I know.
He's dead now.
Yeah, he's dead.
Thank god.
Thank god there's friendly fire.
Oh.
What?
Let me just...
There we go.
He's just standing there, yeah.
He's just like, are you done yet?
And then Goon number five threw a fucking bomb at him.
And I'm like, oh, that works too.
You know, that works.
It's just giving him a little back massage, you know?
Absolutely.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, now I can hack.
There you go.
Nice, first try.
That's it?
What the fuck?
What did that do?
What?
Oh, I was supposed to hack that.
Oops.
Wrong one.
There you go, microwave.
Can I blow up the container?
What does that container do?
Joker's cure.
Where is it?
Ah, forget the clown.
I want Cobbapot.
He has my suit, my weapons.
I'll end him for what he's done to me.
Penguin's mind.
You need to stay focused on that cure, or innocent people will die.
you don't understand i cannot complete my work without it i must have your suit everything depends on it everything what does a suit do himself with your ice gun how do i get past it do i look like a
friend then you die he has get you one year's suit or not victor mr freeze if you're gone what will happen to know leave my wife out of this Batman don't let this situation fool you we are not friends oh fuck bro Batman doesn't kill bro what the fuck Batman doesn't kill guys to stop anyone using my weapons against me how did that work out for you what Why don't you go get the security override and figure out a way to stop him yourself?
It's been a pleasure, Victor.
Bro, give him back the money!
Oh shit!
Bro, is there even anything left in there?
Jesus.
He doesn't kill!
But torture's okay.
What the fuck, Bruce?
Holy shit.
Do you even know how much liquid you left him?
Wait, does that even have enough for even five minutes?
Please understand he's suffering from super AIDS.
He's right in the head.
Oh, talk to him again.
Can I do that?
Sorry for torturing, buddy.
But, like, you want to have a chat?
Oh, yeah, I wanted to do this.
What does this do?
Can I...
Oh, let me hack this real quick, too.
Let me hack the Titan juice.
Oh.
That was one of the Titan containers.
Joker had back at Arkham Asylum.
What is it doing here?
Wait, that's it?
I just blow it up?
Oh, okay.
Is that part of the stuff?
I like some side it must be a side quest or some shit it's sorry for torturing you earlier where you want to have a chat man I thought we had a deal you'll get your suit freeze think cold thoughts while you work on that cure find my suit until I have it I will not help you all right we gotta go get his suit now oops I got a Crouch run shit.
There you go.
I could have just crawled through that, but it doesn't look as cool, I guess.
Wee!
Alright, where do I have to go?
Let's go this way.
It looks like the ice is beginning to fall.
Oh, nice!
That's convenient.
It's got a pole now.
I need to be too careful.
I'm just pulling the boy.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I'll make sure I don't accidentally walk off the platform, though.
Yeah, that's fine.
I'm gonna be as close to that thing as possible.
Apparently I'm weak as fuck when it comes to pulling my ropes.
Alright.
Should be this to the left.
Oh, yeah, I was gonna say, what the fuck?
I want a piece of penguin when you catch him.
Promise me.
Concentrate on keeping him out of here.
He's a dangerous man.
You're emotional.
You'll make mistakes.
Leave him to me.
Like I said, you're emotional.
And then, like, so you can't deal with penguin.
And I literally just, like, ripped out this man's life support.
Because I was suffering from super AIDS.
So that's the famous free-suit.
Oh, what are you doing?
When I leave here, wait 10 minutes.
Then get this over to freeze.
He won't be dangerous.
No problem, Batman.
Hmm?
What a fun.
Oh, what's that?
You used to remotely disable custom design freeze.
Oh, okay.
New weapon.
New gadget.
Now I can confront him.
Yeah, I got his SD card.
Yoink, mine now.
Yeah, it's the override chip.
Alright, gotta head over.
Did I make it?
Guys, I didn't make it.
It's a good thing, Mr. Freeze.
Yeah, it's made it compatible for the Batman suit.
Thank you for the...
Do you think that guy saw it?
I don't think you saw it, right?
She, in fact, did not make it.
Okay.
I pulled myself to it.
Okay, we pulled each other.
That's fine.
But, Balergas, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thing.
Thank you.
What?
That's it.
I'm gonna beat you up.
I'm gonna beat up a fucking shark today.
That's fucking right.
I could have just done it.
that on a lot.
Okay, that looks so fucking goofy.
I literally just punched a shark.
I don't need shark repellent.
I got my fist right here.
I'm gonna give him a goddamn beat down.
So how do I use this?
I'm too far away.
The override won't work this far away.
Oh, wait.
I just got Oh, sorry.
I got so confident after beating down that shark.
I thought I could beat up water
Jesus Oh, oh my god, I'm trying not to I need to get closer to penguin before activating the security override It's just not close enough I can use the security override to get to penguin Come in Africa.
If you don't see it, use the override to get past Penguin.
Wait, how the fuck do I get close enough?
We just have a conversation, bro?
Yeah?
What?
Wait, what?
Oh, fire attack you!
Please help us!
What the hell is wrong with this thing?
Wait, what?
Stay back!
Oh, did I do it?
Oh!
I didn't realize it was me.
I was like, oh, that's convenient.
His gun was jammed.
I'm sorry, please.
Don't hurt me.
I can't guarantee that.
Me neither.
I was like, how convenient.
I tried to help you.
Who did that?
I'm afraid of the opportunity to end this in one way.
walk away but oh no you had to be the big man well guess what from up here you look pretty small
i see a lot was after that fall bro he has like seven like solomon grundy he's real
oh my god what happened to your hair
Born on a Monday
No, don't hurt him He's chey Born on a Monday Christian on Tuesday Married on Wednesday Okay I found him down there when I bought this place.
Comes in handy.
Bro, he's just chill.
He's a homie.
Oh, shit.
So how do I...
Oh, my God.
What?
Okay.
What the fuck does that do?
Oh, shit!
Bro, I...
I don't- What am I supposed to do with quick gel?
I- Where is my quick gel, anyway?
Yeah?
Oh!
Okay.
Okay, I got it.
I got it.
I figured it out.
Context clue, guys.
There we go.
Context clues!
Visual puzzles!
World's greatest detective!
That's me!
Guys, I don't think that tells me.
Oh, my God.
This.
What am I supposed to bat around?
Oh, no.
He's got me.
Oh, shit.
There you go.
I should have.
That should be everything.
Snap out of it, man!
Stop the unstoppable!
I did it!
Finished Grundy!
Oh!
I got the achievement!
It said stop the unstoppable!
Oh shit!
I forgot to struggle.
There was a quick time event.
How do I stop that?
Oh.
Oh my god, okay.
Oh my god, I'm trying to fucking... Please!
Just take it off.
I will brute force this!
There you go.
I have enough HP.
Alright, now...
Now I can beat the shit out of him.
Oh my god, Batman!
Oh my god!
The bat versus the bird.
Bro, I literally...
Did I just like fucking...
Jesus Christ!
I just ripped his heart.
I just beat the shit out of his heart.
That's fine.
You have nothing after I get close to you.
Get out of here, little man.
You wish you were Danny the Vito.
Where is Cobble Pot?
Oh, wait, it's a ninja lady.
Oh, look who it is.
Don't worry.
Next Monday, he'll be back.
Enough.
Of course.
Oh.
You will regret what you did, Mr. Cobblepot.
Interior on exhibit.
The cure, Freeze.
There isn't one.
What?
I was thinking of a super chat thingy, thank you.
Creating an antidote to the disease that afflicts the clown was easy.
Unfortunately, the cure degrades too quickly.
It needs a restorative element, some kind of reforming enzyme.
Without it, it breaks down before it can help its host.
I've seen this before.
Finding a suitable enzyme is not the only problem.
It needs to be adapted, bonded to human DNA.
That will take decades.
time it appears you do not have what if I told you I know a man who's been exposed to that enzyme for centuries what what man yeah his name is Raish Algul bring him to me all I need is a sample of his blood it is your only hope Raish Algul is dead then you and the clown wait is that do wait is that his starter i need someone to tell me where the body is then i can go wake him up
or it's just like a minion you are a fool batman you've let your own yeah like one of his followers no victor if rachel ghoul is in arkham city i now have a trail right to him i thought he was dead Oh,
she, I lied.
Over a century ago, murderer Cyrus Gold Celtics caved justice by hiding Forced doom, the now mortal To end the cycle of death and rebirth Rout of his memories, he adapted The name, born on a Monday Christian on Tuesday Married on Wednesday, took ill on Thursday Grew worse on Friday on saturday buried on sunday this is the end of solomon grundy all right i'll meet him again next monday i guess yeah new gadget i save everyone oh yeah everyone's saved wait what oh i just scan it whoops i thought i was just supposed to i thought already like did everything needed
Okay, scan time.
Oracle, change of plan.
I'm going after the League of Assassins.
Why?
What have been it?
Is this about Rage or his daughter?
Penguin had one of the League's assassins imprisoned in the museum.
Is this before or after Damien?
She's a member of Talia's elite guard.
I knew it.
What is it about that woman that makes her instantly the most important person in your world?
Talia is not the gold guard.
Did this game come up before or after Damien was...
Uh, before?
Okay, so Damien wouldn't exist yet.
Yeah, I was gonna say, is Damien existed yet?
Oh my god, that's just all his blood.
Okay, let's upgrade.
Heek signature.
What's that?
Nah, we don't need that.
Is there anything else that's a good upgrade?
Nah.
I feel like maybe more armor?
I'll do more armor.
I gotta go this way.
Talia, cool.
I don't even know what she looks like in my memory bank.
Where is he?
Oh yeah, I don't.
I don't remember what they look like.
I have early onset dementia apparently for Batman yeah I
did too heavy slowed me down let me know when it's here all right gotta go this way the boss is vanished what where'd
Okay, this lady should die from blood loss.
Like, not even die, just passed out.
Like, that is so much blood.
That is way too much blood, girl.
How do you not have passed out from blood loss?
Wait, the trail went cold.
Where the fuck is she?
Oh, it's over here.
Like, the fact that...
Bro, look...
That is a lot of blood.
Okay, let's get rid of these guys first.
Bro, I'm trying to follow my blood trail and you're...
You're messing it up for me.
Like, here?
Wait, it stopped.
Okay, she jumped down.
Now where?
Where'd she go after?
This way.
she went up oh my god little cat and mouse shit here some parkour stuff that she's doing
and down here and then she climbed up a lamppost okay what does she do after she climbed up this fucking lamppost wait what did she do after here come on no it's up here wait what does she do afterwards okay and then what okay she went this way oh
holy shit why did she have to make this so difficult wait where after oh this way the blood trail has run out the only way I'm gonna find that assassin is to locate more evidence scan assassins banish Oh, here it is.
What, did she, like, catarize her wounds or something?
Who said that?
Oh, there she is.
The only way to find Rage is to get a tracker on that ninja.
I'll need to get in close.
Come here after you.
Come here to get you.
Oops.
Wait, give me a sec.
Can you wait a little bit?
Did I lose her trail?
Oh my gosh, she's over there.
Oh my god, fucked up.
Oh my gosh, she's so fast.
Wait, I think I lost her.
Oh wait, it's so good that she waited for me because she's like suffering from blood loss.
That's very convenient.
Thank god she's limping.
Whoa!
She will continue to live because the great racial rule allows it.
Wait, triplets?
Robin!
I can take her.
Stand down.
Which one?
Which Robin is this?
Dick?
Jason?
Or the other one?
Do not follow us.
Tim!
Oh shit, sorry, Tim.
You need your help.
Really?
That's not what it looked like from where I was standing.
Took me three tries.
I got it under control.
I forgot about Tim.
Sorry, he's the most boring one.
Nobody remembers Tim.
He's like the middle child.
The middle Robin.
Anyone with this blood in them will be dead within 24 hours.
Whose blood is it?
Oh.
It's yours.
Oh my god.
Finally a Robin.
I'll get into the hospitals and come back.
You need my help here.
I can handle it.
you're needed in gotham what has tim even done much worse i don't remember tim's backstory knows who you are what happens if he tells everyone oh yeah people are gonna reveal him trust me i'll find a way
if you need me you know where i am i know no he wasn't no dick was the circus kid jason's the one that got his knees got well not just his knees but his head bashed in by a crowbar, by Joker.
I'm like, what did Tim do?
Allows rapid movement between two or is on can be redeployed.
How many gadgets do I have while riding the change direction?
Yeah.
But Jason has trauma.
Well, all of them have trauma.
Look, Jason's been through a rough time, okay?
he was the middle child until he he got he got crowbarred then we just then we had to be nice to him after that also he's a robin that shoots a gun that's already pretty badass he's literally the only robin that uses a gun everyone has trauma he's not he's coming back no one knows how but he will
side wait where am i going
wait how much okay wait the biggest thing tim has done is he's a robin who introduced pants to the robin brand he also figured out who batman was that's the whole thing just some guy they give us super chat thank you thank you Okay, so how do I do this?
Yeah, but everyone eventually figure out who Bruce Batman is.
He ain't special.
We all figured it out.
But he- I mean, good for him for letting the Robins have pants.
Alright, what?
Like, he gave me this tool.
What?
Bro, that's my girlfriend.
Who said that?
Bro, who the fuck said that?
That's my girlfriend over there.
I don't know what to do with this.
They're talking about my girl again.
The prison is better than this.
Arkham City is an equal opportunities penal facility.
Oh, there it is.
Where in my house?
heading to is that the tracker that's a tracker right oh god my fucking ex is trying to contact me what does he want i hope you're doing your
oops bro
he he's so obsessed with me man ever since like you know i broke up with him you just can't i just live rent free in his head bro i mean like bro this guy gave me super aids i had to break up with him like He told me he was clean.
And then I got super aids.
He's so obsessed, man.
Where is the...
Oh, it's this way.
Is this where the tracker's taking me?
I gotta get him out of here first.
Can I say thank you for the super chat?
Thank you, thank you.
I feel bad for Tim.
Tim went on...
Dick went on to become Nightwing.
Jason went on to become Red Hood.
Tim went on to become Red Robin.
To be fair.
Tim really needs to move on from the whole Robin brand.
This is why nobody remembers him.
Like Damien's the son of Batman.
Dick is the first Robin.
Jason used to be the middle child.
And then, like, you know.
He died, so like we all feel bad for him.
And then there's Tim.
Alright, it's this way.
See, is that Assassin, like, moving?
Oh my god, she is!
I didn't even realize she's been moving this entire time.
I can't even... What?
Where is she?
She's right below me.
That does not make sense What oh my god.
Oh my okay.
It's fine.
Okay, I'm gonna use this What the fuck wait what oh shit?
Okay, I did not know I could do that that was actually a mis-input That's crazy.
Oh fuck Okay, I realized that they all had guns Okay, that was pretty cool I sort of fucked up though after that Because I got a little too greedy.
I got a little too greedy there.
Oh my god, let's do this again.
Where the fuck are they?
So what's up with Batman going in the museum?
Like he's in, she's in the tunnel.
Wait, was that one of the hardest challenges?
Like, that's hard to do?
But how do I get in the tunnel?
Wait,
how do I get in there?
Yeah, but where are the goons?
Is it here?
Oh,
there's the hole.
Okay, there it is.
I forgot where the hole was.
Oh, fuck!
That's right.
Can't get...
Whoa, don't!
Get in the hole, Batman!
Can't get me.
I'm in the hole now.
Alright.
We did it.
Gotham's a maze of old steel and ironwork.
What?
What the fuck?
My signal may get weak.
Try and stay locked on.
Rerouting additional satellite coverage now.
Good luck, Bruce.
Okay, the swamp water is bad water.
This way?
Oh my god, when you said it was a maze...
I didn't realize it was a maze maze.
Hello guys.
Okay, thank god.
You guys didn't have- you're not the- you're not the gun goons.
That's all that matters.
Jesus Christ.
Bro, I can't even dodge it.
Bro, please, please!
That's it!
It's time!
Oh my god, he's- oh, whoops.
I'll take those.
Re-kill.
There we go.
Finish her!
Jesus.
I sent one to the pit, too.
Joker's got his crew moving through the sewers.
Hunting down what's left of Penguin's thugs.
Look, it's him not being able to swim.
It's not my fault.
I didn't intentionally kill him.
Him drowning is just an accident.
Wait, what is it?
Uh-oh.
I see the Joker teeth, but like, do I get anything out of that?
I don't even know if I got anything out of it.
Weeeee!
Oh shit, it's supposed to be here.
How do I get over there?
This way?
No?
maybe here there you
go okay this way okay
listen up the last of the penguins crews will hold up somewhere up ahead the joker wants to be found do we kill them up to us i say we kill them half of penguins crews were murks never trust them murk like i say it's up to us we'll see what happens when we catch it How do I get down here?
Okay.
I just gotta figure out how to get down there.
Oh, there it is.
Okay, there's explosive.
Oh, okay, never mind.
I make my own exit.
That's right.
I love the explosive.
Just so dumb.
Oh, shit!
That's right.
You ain't setting me up.
no alarm here wait what's that oh my god get over here get your ass out of that gun get over here he ain't fucking opening a gun no gun for you yeah oh no he He got the gun.
He got the gun.
But I got my Batarang.
It's fine.
Finish it.
I love that the Batarang was the one that kills him.
I feel like I'm not supposed to... I feel like this is not where Raza Ghoul's assassin is.
I don't know.
I feel like being further and further away from the assassin.
Oh, thank God.
I'm heading the right way.
Thank God.
I was starting to doubt it.
I felt like I was on, like, some random side quest.
Oops.
Yeah.
Oh, that's not it.
There you go.
Go up.
Did he just give me XP?
Oh, it does.
Oh, am I drunk?
What the fuck is going on?
Oh, it's my blood.
That's my super aides.
Just give me a minute.
I'll be all right.
No, you won't.
Hurry.
You're running out of time.
Oh, no.
It's spreading to my brains.
Guns, explosives.
thermal trackers what the fuck is going on with my just music what are you saying joke is my man you know that been in his crew for years so stop asking questions you know they don't like questions okay sorry just seems weird that's all guys I I don't know if this is considered stealth,
but we'll find out.
Do you think they know that I was there?
Do you think I got away with it?
Okay, nice.
Okay, that's fine.
I got away with it.
I don't know how.
I don't know how, but I think I'll get away with it.
Jesus Christ.
What are you gonna do, man?
There are so many people!
Okay, it's fine.
Slam dunk!
Okay, nice.
Got your leg!
I wish...
I wish the explosives was lethal.
But at least he can give me a quick stun.
There you go.
I countered with my fist.
That counts, right?
It looks like Joker is sending his crew down to steal weapons off the Tiger Guards.
That's not good.
Those guys are armed with the latest military weapons.
If Joker gets his hands on that stuff, well, you know.
He won't.
I won't let him.
I did it, guys.
I countered with my fist.
That's all, that's the same thing.
This is a great offense.
Look what we got here.
What's up, Doc?
Please don't hurt me.
Oh, we ain't gonna hurt you, sweet.
Not a pretty little thing like you.
Please.
I'm an intern.
I don't know what's going on here.
Bro, she's just an intern.
She's here for exposure.
Get the rest of the guns out and stack them up over there.
We're on a schedule here.
What are these things?
Military grade interference generators.
Best money.
Am I on a sad quest?
I don't think there's no...
Is Raul Ghul even here?
Okay, no, that's main quest.
I was gonna say it.
Let's just have to do with Raul Ghul and the assassins.
Not nice people.
Oh, God.
Please.
I can't fix him.
Please let me go.
Sorry, Doc.
Okay, that's where I'm supposed to be.
I got...
confused don't try to run I'd hate to have to punish you you got such a pretty face yeah you don't want a bullet going through it me my favorite the hammer more personal now you can feel every blow understand the complexity of the human body as it's deconstructed into a primordial sludge that's deep man I had you all wrong I told you just like hitting people with hammers who told you Are you just really like hammers,
bro?
Is this situation requiring savoring lives?
Is this...
Okay, but she didn't have a name.
Okay, so she clearly isn't that important.
She's just a doctor.
How is I supposed to know she was an important doctor?
Guys, I don't think I hid.
It's fine.
They don't know.
That's right.
Couldn't see me.
Random bullshit.
Let's go.
It always works.
I told you.
Pocket sand.
Can you hear me?
Thank God it's you!
Where are my guns?
Help me!
They are very important in my planter.
Who?
Are you still down there, Bats?
It's me!
Did you keep getting away with this?
That's right.
Batter ran over guns.
Don't worry, I got you, girl.
That's my new girlfriend.
Where am I?
thank you what are you doing in arkham city i'm in arkham city what the hell am i doing here i was grabbed outside the hospital i interned at god this is an intern i like how i like your trust just has the word intern on it joker looks like you were unlucky he's dying right it seems that way how do you know not to feel bad about that what now i mean he did murder thousands of people I'll be back.
Wait, why am I... Okay, I have to save.
Oh, yeah, I was gonna say why am I...
Oh, yeah, because he's dying from the same disease as I am.
Joker's not stealing the weapons from Strange.
Strange is giving Joker the weapons.
Oh, are you sure?
Of course we are.
Why would he do that?
Maybe he's trying to control who runs the streets.
I'm going to look into it.
Okay, but shouldn't you find Rage first?
I'm doing that now.
Don't worry, Barbara.
All right.
Okay, now back to my regular mission.
It's this way.
I think it's this way?
Back to what I was originally supposed to be doing.
Welcome to Wonder City.
Oh no, I'm tripping out, dude.
Oh no.
God, that's not good.
I don't think...
I don't think that's water.
Do you think that's good blood or bad blood?
Guys, I think... I think I'm having a bad trip.
This man's mistakes nail the coffin shut.
But this doesn't have to be your future.
There!
Everywhere!
What?
Oh, this is assassins.
Behind this wall is mankind's chance for survival.
A glimpse of the future based on an amazing discovery.
You guys think that was ketchup, guys?
When did I eat ketchup?
Peep out or die.
Intrigued.
Then step closer.
Witness the future of Gotham City.
Okay, I think...
On their city.
Oh.
You know what?
Fuck this.
Wait, they can dodge the batterang?
Wait, you can do that?
Oh my god.
That's not fair?
Oh
my god, there's so many.
Oh my god, there's so many ladies ladies, ladies, please ladies
Of course they can't Get dodged forever Get out of here Get out of here, get dodged, oh shit Alright, okay, I gotta beat Oh my god Okay, nice.
Oh my god, a stupid fucking sword
How the fuck did I kill the first one so fast?
Can't dodge us forever
See, I told you she can't dodge it forever my fist has no cooldown Discovery that will allow Gotham to rise like Lazarus becoming a beacon of hope for this world Oh.
Unconscious.
See?
Look, they're all alive.
Who's dead?
Who fucking actually died?
I seem to see so...
That's not me.
Batman doesn't kill.
...providing clean, safe energy.
...
Okay.
Are we in Bioshock?
Oh
my god, it's Bioshock.
I'm in the underwater city.
Yeah, counter.
It's Y.
It's literally this.
It's Rapture.
But the door looks like it's been sealed for decades.
It literally does look like Rapture.
The assassins must be using another way to get through.
These must be the famous mechanical guardians of Wonder City.
It looks like their inner workings were very advanced.
I'm detecting a kind of memory tape they used, almost a primitive video.
Perhaps I can scan and analyze it.
Would you kindly go take care of the Joker?
Scan the thing.
I'm hacking.
I'm stealing your memories.
Oh shit!
The data is incomplete.
This is way ahead of the technology that should have been available back then.
It looks like the data is stored in a shared memory pool.
Maybe I just gotta find the other bots.
I mean there's one here.
Come on, give me your data.
I gotta go find the cloud.
It's nice that they all have, they all share the same cloud.
Is this someone already scanned?
Thank God they all backed up.
Backed it up.
Can I do it from this guy?
Oh, I can.
That's good.
And then one right here.
Oh, shit!
What the fuck?
I knew I should have killed.
God damn it!
Fat Man, sometimes you just gotta...
Look what happened!
You didn't put her in conscious enough She should have been like a vegetable
Alright Get her out of here Oh my god, were they like all triplets or some shit
That's right In the head you go Okay now Now they should be fully unconscious There's no way Also chat died again I got refreshed Okay That's so annoying.
It's a bit...
I don't know why Chad dies there.
Alright.
Diagnol, welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Did I analyze everything?
There's still one more here.
There we go.
I think there's like another one?
How many more do I need?
Oh, shit.
Shit!
God damn it.
I don't know if these are the same assassins or like...
Or like the same two that I literally just knocked out.
Alright, there we go.
We'll have it not scanned yet.
Oh, one more.
I see it.
Oh, no, I don't.
I've lost track.
How do I get to her?
Oh, it's here.
Oh, it's new ones.
Oh, they take their dress codes very seriously.
Are you fucking...
Get out of here!
I'm trying to hack!
Bro, I'm trying to update my iPhone.
I'm so fucking rude.
Alright, that's fine.
Boom!
Alright.
Now I can fully hack.
God damn it.
Stupid iPhone.
I don't know which one I haven't done it yet.
This is a blue?
Oh, I guess if it's blue I haven't hacked it.
Okay.
What the fuck is that?
Cuddle me this.
Is that Titan?
Oh, I didn't finish.
Okay.
Because I got interrupted.
I didn't realize I got interrupted.
The assembled surveillance footage shows me where the assassin went.
She must have been using a secret entrance.
I need to find it.
You mean like this?
Wow, it's so secret.
Oh my god, where could that button be?
I guess I'll never know.
it looks like a sword fits here guess i'll never know oh how convenient all right put that sword in nice against the brick wall Batman never kills the world's greatest detective
this way
yeah they give us a super chat.
Thank you.
Batman parent believes in equal rights and equal lives.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Rated E for everyone.
Am I okay?
Oh my God.
Oh, it's in my blood.
I mean, it was in my bloodstream.
But you could tell.
Oh my gosh.
Am I in like Utopia now?
Walt Disney?
Oh my God.
Mom?
Dad?
I knew you guys baked your deaths your father and i are waiting father the light brucey
i knew you fake your deaths we need you to do it bruce bruce can you hear me your vitals they're dropping
oh how long have i got oh
i'll make it it's okay we got this guys And even if I don't make it, I'll get to see mommy and daddy again.
Like, what's the worst thing that could happen?
Feels like a lot of pros over the cons.
I was wondering, if I just stood there, would I have just died?
It's like a win-win.
Oh, is that my girlfriend?
Hey, girl.
I'm dying.
Oh shit.
Hello Talia.
How did you find us?
I recognized your personal guard.
It was just a matter of following her.
Please, mistress, he tricked me.
Leave.
I will deal with you later.
You didn't need to get yourself arrested to see me, Bruce.
After that night we spent in Metropolis.
Oh.
Damn.
me get tested where's reish if he's dead again i need you to wake him up only a true successor may stand before the great rachel my father always intended us to be together to command his army just imagine it you me a better world
Like, oh my god, no, that's super age.
You wish to become an assassin.
Why should I just- She's freaked out.
She's like, do I have to go to the hospital too?
Does it look like I have a choice?
Are you prepared to take the demon trials?
You must show you are willing to take a life to save the world.
I'm ready.
Then let the trials commence.
Is that contagious?
Yeah.
Bro, I don't think I'm okay.
Anyway, I was wondering, you know what I was like, when Barbara was like, you have minutes.
If I stood there, could I have died.
Talia, I have literally minutes.
I don't know if I can do this trial.
Thousands of warriors have fallen in pursuit of the demon.
Bro, I'm not feeling so good.
Would the successors have proven to be nothing more than children.
Where is my immersion?
I've seen worse.
Oh my god, look at the way she's walking right now.
Destiny will decide your fate.
She knows she's got it.
She's a baddie.
I have heard these words a hundred times.
Let us hope you are correct.
She know what she got.
Your journey begins through this door.
Let's get started.
Are you sure, Bruce?
Only one man has passed this ordeal.
Are you trying to talk me out of this?
Of course not.
I just...
I just want you to be certain.
When the blood of the demon takes hold, you will be on your own.
Like always.
Then may the spirits be kind.
Just believe in me.
That's fucked up.
I thought we tight like that.
Oh yeah, Ration.
I don't know.
I can pronounce this thing raw, ghouls.
Demon Trial.
Simply drink from the chalice.
It is that simple.
Good.
What's in this?
Feel the blood of the demon coursed through your veins, restoring your health, and twisting your will.
What even was in that?
Your next task is simple.
Follow me through this world, and the trial is complete.
That sounds easy.
Just drugs, yeah.
Just like eight different kinds of drugs all blended in together.
Nothing too...
No, nothing too bad.
Wait, he said follow him.
Where did he go?
He's like, just follow me.
How do I follow someone that just fucking disappeared?
Okay.
Okay, it said dive bomb.
Okay, I did not know I'm gonna...
erupt into like fucking smoke and dust.
A steady climb to cover alternative between it didn't let me do anything there.
Okay, there we go.
I was like, so...
It's so weird.
I thought that...
I legitimately thought that that was a ledge that I could... Okay, guys.
I would say I...
I thought that was a ledge.
I thought that was a ledge, okay.
I thought it was a ledge that I could land on.
How the fuck was I supposed to know?
I can't touch that.
Where did he go?
Oh my god, it's time.
Oh my god!
Okay.
I didn't realize it was time.
I thought it would stop moving.
okay all right stopped i had to land there for it to stop prove if you are strong enough to leave my forces to save this world from the evil that is destroying it what just fucking gliding i'm just gliding how does that prove anything
how the fuck does gliding even prove anything
oh god i'm not gonna make it i'm not gonna make it or not.
Alright.
Oh my god, I already fucked it up.
I'm so lost.
Oh no.
Oh no, it's over.
It's so over.
Goodbye.
It's so hard to pull up.
I don't know why.
Okay, there you go.
Oh my god, it's like Dolphining in Apex again.
I feel like I'm playing Apex again.
I feel...
It's literally the Apex Dolphining.
What the fuck?
Get out of here.
But I can't push him off the ledge.
I hate that.
Bro, I'm fucking...
Get out of here!
Wait, I can't dodge that.
I'm trying to.
That's right, Sandman.
Are you the one I have searched for, Detective?
The one to succeed me.
I did press Y, but if I have, like, I realize, like, if I'm pressed, if my analog stick is, like, um, it's, like, pressed, it, like, doesn't register my Y.
It's so weird.
I'm not supposed to land in here.
Are you serious?
Yeah, like my analog stick is like...
Because sometimes I have my analog stick.
I'm just like moving my analog stick with it, too.
And then like the Y doesn't register.
It's so weird.
Imagine the good that you could do with such a gift.
Oh, I think I'm going to hit that.
I forgot the rest of it.
I was like, why am I not flying?
Okay, there you go.
I was like, well, I don't understand.
I swear to God, if my leg touches that, oh my God, oh my God, I fucked up.
No!
It's okay.
still make it guys maybe maybe maybe no where did he go where did he go you're about to piss me up rage bait successful nice okay here you go got it
hello i can see your body is becoming weaker The small quantity that I have allowed you to drink will only keep you alive for a few more precious hours.
Hours?
I mean, I had minutes before.
I'll take those.
I'll take that.
Oh, that's like expanding it to, like, 20 years.
This way?
Okay.
Alright, nice.
Yay!
Oops.
Get out of here.
Wait, watch this.
Boom.
Oh, oh, that works.
That's our intention.
Look at that.
It is time to face me in person.
Complete this final challenge.
And the blood of the devil gives you the gift of eternal life
See it just works
Am I supposed to die bomb that
Where am I
Oh, I'm in a house Now Come and find me.
Collect your great lord.
Oh, shit.
They like me now.
I'm part of you guys.
I'm part of the crew.
Solid Snake, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Relatable.
Silk song was a bit harder after all the abuse the A-button had with all the mashing hidden monster out of it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You did it.
You sound surprised.
Of course not.
I always had faith.
Where's Rache?
I need to see him now.
I'm running out of time.
Your final challenge awaits you through this door.
I pray the spirits will be kind.
You're back!
How many times I have to kill you, old man?
Oh, he is not looking so good.
Wait, do you also have Super 8?
What the fuck?
I thought you were- Joker and Oxclus!
Oh no, you're just fucking dead.
Never mind, you're just a zombie.
Never mind.
It is your destiny.
I will never kill.
Not even you.
What?
You lied to me.
I needed a sample of your father's blood.
I will never kill.
The fucking biggest liar.
I love her.
To help you.
Use my sword.
Take it all.
No.
And that is your final...
That's funny, Batman.
Yeah, but the mountains of debt that I've prescribed over the criminals will surely kill them.
But that's their own choice.
Not because of me.
Okay, well, now...
Oh, he's back alive!
Okay.
Wait, can you just do that?
Wait, can I just use this fucking pool?
Now, only one of us can leave this chamber alive.
Wait, I could have used that to cure me!
What kind of consequences does it have?
I think like, Batman's already sort of insane if you think about it.
Like, he's literally hanging by a thread.
I feel like he's already there.
I don't think he's, like, sane at all.
Like, who dresses up as a fucking bat, to be fair?
Like, if your first...
If your first response is to dress up as a bat, Jesus Christ.
your parents died and then like try and like defend the city of crime like i don't think you're mentally like saying witness the true power of my mentally stable what the do i do with that oh okay
like what do i do with okay there you go i okay i get it There we go.
Ew.
It's stupid.
It's so stupid.
I'm sorry, this is a dumbass boss fight.
I don't like this boss fight.
It's just stupid.
This is so dumb.
Don't worry, my sad people are a little Save me.
It's so goofy.
Cut his throat!
Fat Man doesn't kill!
Clean of the scum of humanity.
Only we can do this.
My father is old.
His time is over.
Hours is just beginning.
Take his blade.
Kill him.
Accept your destiny.
except our destiny you know I can't do that tell you then beloved you will have to die what do you mean I thought we'd be together for ever okay but what if oh my God.
That's fucking right.
Gotcha now!
Jesus, when he does that dash thing, it throws me off.
Yeah.
Okay.
Our numbers are too great.
Oh, fuck this.
I'm just gonna hit you.
I'm just gonna beat you up.
Oh my god, I didn't see him.
I don't know how to dodge that other guy when he does that dash.
You cannot beat us.
How do you dodge that dash over there?
Like this dash.
Do I just press A?
But I have to have someone else there.
Oh, is it A?
Okay.
Yeah, it was A.
Okay, I know now.
What?
You should have joined us.
That's not fair.
Okay.
Oh, where is he?
I swear to God, it's a taser.
It's taser time.
It's a fucking stupid ass taser.
It's taser time, buddy.
Oh shit.
Where's the horde?
Where the fuck is the horde?
Taser tab.
So stupid.
This is the stupidest boss fight ever.
I literally hate this boss fight because of how dumb this is.
There's such a dumb boss fight.
Okay, that was bullshit.
The slowly rotating soldier.
Counter,
counter, counter, counter, counter, counter, counter, counter, counter.
You don't use the gun, bitch.
That's right.
Get Jojo.
What are you doing?
Listen to me, detective, and listen well.
You will kill me.
Lead the League of Assassins because if you do not join us, I will kill why does that have to be you have ever loved?
What was it part of the plan?
Don't tell cat woman don't sh Don't tell cat woman that she's not listening is she?
That loose back on his lieutenant from Brian and leaving them do it Do it
it nice I did it Kahlia I didn't kill your dad and give me your blood Jesus Christ bro I fucking took that from his cheek you should have killed me yes he should have what kind of a man sacrifices his own daughter and you Oh yeah, no, Bruce Wayne has an incredible,
terrible taste in women.
He's like, I can fix her.
But he could never fix her.
You two deserve each other.
You're looking old, Rage.
What's really going on here?
I have used the Lazarus Pit too many times.
I've lived 600 years.
My mind and body cannot take much more.
Each time I enter the pit, I am frightened of what will come out.
The Lazarus pit has corrupted your mind.
Think about it.
If your pit falls into the wrong hands, you'll be powerless to stop centuries of destruction.
This is your chance for redemption, Rage.
Call off your crusade, or I'll be back for you.
pit it one more time isn't he there's no way he's like one more time when it hurt sorry to disappoint you did you find rash hold on your suits readings are back to normal are you cured what's going on i cured super ace are based underneath arkham city extracts his blood has a lazarus pit in there called lazarus yeah he's been using it for centuries slowly perfecting the until he was even so where did I go crazy from the dead I mean crazier he forced me to small doses appear to heal most ailments but even the small amount I ingested had a nasty side effects prolonged exposure as I would say I would I feel like let's keep upgrading armor I feel like I get a little crazier yeah no Raish tried to convince me to use his pit but the risks are too great when I'm done here I'll need to investigate this Lazarus technology further I told Raish absolutely thank you oh god god damn it riddler unlikely Raish is addicted to the pit absolutely give us super chat thank you thank you break that
addiction or I'll be back to do it myself I gotta leave Wonder City get you that blood sample yeah he's down at Gotham General it's going crazy there I'll catch through hey bar you it's me what's happening there Bruce it's not good Gotham general has at least 30 confirmed cases there are nearly 50 at mercy well that's not good all over the city I've run a simulation Joker's blood could be in as many as 2,000
people by morning 2,000 people Jesus Christ how many people are getting blood transfusions right now what sample I extracted from race will complete the formula I hope you're right Also, where am I?
I don't know, I'll fucking backtrack this.
Oh my god, I wish there were fast travel.
I'm legitimately lost.
I don't know how to backtrack any of this.
There's those 2,000 people, I guess.
There's no way all 2,000 of these people live.
Oh, it's back here.
door behind me okay exits this way it's gonna say like where the fuck am i i legitimately don't even remember this thank god i have a map also thea they give us super chat thank you thing yeah rest in peace and batman i wouldn't even yes hey for a fatty like talia he has the self-restraint
That's true.
I don't know how he does it.
How the fuck does Batman do it?
I don't think any of us would hesitate.
Goddamn Riddler.
You're not gonna get any of that money back, Riddler.
Like this investment isn't even worth it.
Yeah.
Cable.
I was finished here.
We just need to wait.
Then head into the tunnels and take out the rest of them.
Can't wait.
It'll be a regular...
I'll get out of here.
Guys, you know how I also eat it?
Thank you for the rain.
Thank you.
How the fuck do I get out of here?
Where did I come from?
This map isn't helpful.
It just says restricted area.
I'm going to get to the museum.
Take out Penguin.
What is that?
It's the back.
Oh, I can't...
Well, I guess...
I'll just die.
Fuck it.
Okay.
How does he see me?
It's just smoke!
I didn't realize he had heat sensors.
That's my bad.
Gotta get out of here.
I don't think he saw me.
I think he saw me.
Oh shit!
He sniped me.
Rice, thank you for five gift and cheers, thank you, thank you.
I'm so confused.
Like, where am I?
Where am I?
I don't know where I...
No!
Yes, I know.
I'm gonna call it here.
I'm too lost, right?
I'm too tired to backtrack out of this hellhole.
I'm too tired to backtrack.
track the subway I'm too exhausted for that my brain is like looking at the map I'm like where the fuck is the exit like future doki will handle the backtrack yeah but I'll be guys enjoyed um part 2 of Batman it's been fun I love all the little references and um nods to like the other um um to like you know other stories in batman and the lore of batman as well as not just batman but like you know the other characters in dc so it's nice i really love like um the little inside easter eggs that they put around the maps to be like oh i know this i know that oh my god look at that but it's been fun I'm I was getting a little tired.
I think you guys can tell I was like yawning a lot because I was getting a little tired today Um, I did have I don't know why I think I did sleep I didn't have enough sleep right after arrivals this this morning Um, I had like I slept for another like five hours So it's not like I didn't sleep enough because I woke up at like around 1 p.m But I don't know I think I'm just like tired from just yesterday.
I think from cleaning my apartment.
I think that's why my body's still recovering from that but i still had a lot of fun um thank you for the five give the chips damage thank you thank you uh no no rivals tonight guys tomorrow i have a really packed day i have like a long day of like work that i have to do behind the scenes um like recordings i have to do behind the scenes um and uh not singing recordings but like um behind the scenes stuff um and also we do have uh tomorrow i'm excited to try this new game out uh the what's called harb harbun i don't remember the name of the game it starts with an h harbunicus or something um but it's like some like it's like alice in wonderland but like a twisted tail like a twisted um take on it and i always enjoyed or harbor bro bro all right ah habromania harbormania um but it's looks really interesting i think the art style looks really interesting in general but i always love how i love stories where they um um where they do like a twisted take on it so um and and i think like
alison wonderland is a good example like a good i guess like a good starting point for stories like that so it's gonna be interesting then i know i said interesting a lot wow i'm tired
it'll be cool to check it out but it's only a demo but uh it's only a demo though so i think like i checked and it was like around an hour long so it'll be a very short stream tomorrow but um i do have a very long day in terms of behind the scenes stuff so i think that's okay that means i get to rest a little bit in between and guys i'm gonna go rest my brain fried my brain is fried right now as always everybody Stay hydrated,
posture, check it up, and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you still, for me, head to bed because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.